IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE A.I. AND
RESEARCH TEAM AT MICROSOFT, DR.
HARRY SHUM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO, EVERYONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
EXACTLY A YEAR AGO AT SAN
FRANCISCO, WE INTRODUCED THE NEW
DIVISION OF MICROSOFT CALLED THE
MICROSOFT A.I. AND RESEARCH.
AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE MISSION
TO DEMOCRATIZE A.I. FOR
EVERYONE.
SO IT HAS BEEN A VERY EXCITING
YEAR IN -- YEAR.
2017 HAS BEEN DELIVERED TO BE AN
EXCITING YEAR.
SO I'M HERE TO SHARE SOME OF THE
PROGRESS WITH YOU, I APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHOW YOU
ESPECIALLY SOME VERY PRACTICAL
WAYS THAT A.I. IS HELPING
EVERYONE TO IMPROVE OUR LIVES.
EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT A.I.
NOWADAYS, BUT A.I. IS REALLY NOT
NEW.
A.I. IS SOMETHING, REALLY THE
ULTIMATE GOAL THAT IN THE MINDS
PEOPLE LIKE ALAN TOURING, THOSE
PEOPLE IMAGINE THAT SOMEDAY IF
WE HAVE THIS UNBELIEVABLE
COMPUTING POWER, WHAT COULD WE
DEALER.
THE FIRST THING ALAN TOURING
REALIZED IMAGINING DOING A.I. IS
MIMICKING HUMG
MIMICKING HUMAN INTELLIGENCE.
AND MICROSOFT, OUR VERY OWN BILL
GATES, WHEN HE CREATED MICROSOFT
RESEARCH 26 YEARS AGO, HE
IMAGINED THAT SOMEDAY COMPUTERS
COULD SEE, HEAR, TALK, AND
UNDERSTAND WHA
UNDERSTAND WHUMAN BEINGS.
THAT'S A.I.
AND A.I. IS HAPPENING NOW FAST.
YOU KNOW, WHY IS THAT?
TO ME IT'S THREE FORCES CONVERG
TO ME IT'S THREE FORCES CON
CONVERGING TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
IT'S THE BIG BETA.
I'M ALWAYS AWARE -- WHETHER IT'S
IoT AND EVERYTHING, AND MASSIVE
COMPUTING POWER WITH THE CLOUD.
MOST RECENTLY THE BREAKTHROUGH
ALGORITHMS LIKE DEEP LEARNING
THAT MOVED A.I. FROM THE LAST TO
THE MAINSTREAM.
TODAY WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE
EVERYDAY A.I.
A.I. IS AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE
EVERYWHERE, AND WHATEVER YOU DO
IN YOUR PERSONAL AND THE
PROFESSIONAL LIFE.
SO HOW A.I.'S GOING TO HELP.
BUT IN MANY WAYS, IF YOU READ
THE PRESS, A.I. HAS GOTTEN A BAD
REPUTATION BECAUSE MUCH OF THE
A.I. DISCUSSION IS ABOUT HUMANS
VERSUS MACHINES.
BUT NOT ENOUGH ABOUT A.I.
POSSIBILITIES.
WE KNOW A.I. WILL TRANSFORM
EVERY BUSINESS, HELP IN EVERY
LIFE, AND POTENTIALLY SOLVE SOME
SOCIETAL CHALLENGES THAT WE ALL
FACE.
YOU MIGHT ASK THAT, THAT'S
GREAT, BUT WHAT ABOUT MICROSOFT
A.I.?
WE BELIEVE THAT A.I. COMES DOWN
TO ONE THING -- PEOPLE.
A.I. WILL AMPLIFY HUMAN
INGENUITY MAKING PEOPLE THE
HEROES AND DRIVING A HEALTHY
CONNECTION BETWEEN HUMANS AND
THE MACHINES.
THAT'S WHAT WE BELIEVE AT
MICROSOFT.
AFTER ALL, THAT'S REALLY ABOUT
MICROSOFT'S MISSION THAT IS
EMPOWER EVERY PERSON AND EVERY
ORGANIZATION ON THE PLANET TO
ACHIEVE MORE.
NOW I WOULD EVEN ADD WITH A.I.
IT'S A POWERFUL MISSION.
NOT TOO LONG AGO, SATYA SHARED
OUR WORLD VIEW, THAT IS THE
INTELLIGENT CLOUD AND THE
INTELLIGENT EDGE INFUSED BY A.I.
IN A WAY IT'S ABOUT COMPUTING
AND INTELLIGENCE FINALLY
HAPPENING WITH P.C
HAPPENING WITH P. KRMP
AND INTELLIGENCE FINALLY
HAPPENING WITH P. KC. PHONES, AD
HAPPENING WITH P. KC. PHONES, A
THE IoT DEVICES.
IMAGINE THAT YOU WALK INTO ANY
ROOM, YOU KNOW, YOU WALK TO YOUR
SPEAKER, YOU WALK TO A SCREEN.
YOU DON'T REALIZE THOSE THINGS
ARE HAPPENING, EXISTING IN THE
ROOM.
THEN YOU CAN ALREADY, YOU KNOW,
TALK TO CORTANA TO GET THINGS
DONE.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE ACROSS THE ROOM
WITH THE HELP OF THE VIEW OF THE
-- WITHOUT THE VIEW OF THE
CAMERAS AND SPEAKERS.
OUR GOAL IS TO HELP EVERYONE
EVERYWHERE AND THAT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A.I. EVERY DAY.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY SATYA AND I
CREATED IT, OUR A.I. IN THE
RESEARCH DIVISION, AND A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR AGO.
IT HAS BEEN AN EXCITING YEAR AND
WITH RESEARCHERS AND ENGINEERS
WORKING TOGETHER CLOSELY, WE'RE
MAKING GREATER PROGRESS, IN
PARTICULAR WE'RE LEVERAGING
TALENT AND TECHNOLOGY COMING OUT
OF OUR MICROSOFT RESEARCH LABS
BY ACCELERATING THE CYCLE FROM
RESEARCH TO THE PRODUCT.
TAKE A QUICK LOOK AT THE VIDEO
ABOUT SOME EXCITING THINGS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING LAST YEAR.
[ NO AUDIO ]
HOW WE HELP PEOPLE WITHOUT
VOICES, HOW THEY CAN COMMUNICATE
WITHOUT A.I.
CLEARLY I COULD USE SOME HELP
HERE, TOO.
YEAH.
>> IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR PRODUCTS
INTO THE HANDS --
♪
>> IT'S GREAT TO SEE IDEAS AND
TECHNOLOGIES THAT HAVE COME
SMACK IN THE MIDDLE OF OUR
PRODUCTS AND INTO THE HANDS OF
OUR USERS.
>> YOU HAVE LUNCH WITH TONY AT
C.J.'S FROM 12:30 TO 1:30 P.M.
>> IT'S CHANGING THE WAY THAT WE
WORK WITH THE LAND, AND IT'S
CHANGING THE WAY THE LAND WORKS
FOR US.
>> TALK AND LOOK IS NOT
ELIGIBLE.
HOLD STEADY.
LEASE AGREEMENT.
♪
>> HEY, CORTANA?
WHAT'S MY SCHEDULE TODAY?
>> A.I. IS GOING TO CHANGE
EVERYDAY LIFE.
OUR GOAL IS THAT WE MAKE IT A
LOT BETTER FOR PEOPLE.
♪
>> THIS IS, OF COURSE, A SMALL
SAMPLE OF SO MANY THINGS
HAPPENING IN MICROSOFT WITH A.I.
AND R.
I WANT TO EXPLAIN THE AREAS THAT
WE ACTUALLY MAKE INVESTMENTS.
THERE ARE FIVE THINGS WE DO WITH
MICROSOFT A.I. AND R.
AND WE STARTED WITH MICROSOFT
RESEARCH.
THERE WAS A LOT OF
GROUNDBREAKING A.I. TECHNOLOGY
THERE THAT WOULD BUILD A LOT OF
A.I. PRODUCTS.
LIKE PRODUCTS LIKE BING AND
CORTANA HELPING YOU WITH
EVERYDAY LIFE.
AND INFUSING A.I. INTO ALL
MICROSOFT PRODUCTS, YOU KNOW,
WITH WINDOWS OFFICE AND MANY
OTHERS.
AND THE PLATFORMS IS TRULY A
CLOUD IN THE A.I. PLATFORM THAT
CAN HELP MICROSOFT DEVELOPERS TO
REVIEW THEIR A.I. APPLICATIONS.
AND WE ALSO SEE INCDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE WITH A.I.
SOLUTIONS.
PRACTICALLY EVERY VERTICAL
INDUSTRY WILL BE DISRUPTED,
WHETHER IT'S HEALTH CARE OR
TRANSPORTATION.
AND EVERY HORIZONTAL BUSINESSES
PROCESS, WHETHER MARKETING,
SALES, CUSTOMER SUPPORT, WILL BE
DISRUPTED BY A.I.
WE'LL SEE INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE.
LET ME FIRST OF ALL SHOW YOU A
FEW HIGHLIGHTS OF THE COOLEST
TECHNOLOGY WE'VE DEVELOPED FROM
MICROSOFT RESEARCH, GETTING INTO
THE REAL PRODUCTS.
THE FIRST EXAMPLE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS ON SPEECH RECOGNITION.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO, WE
ANNOUNCED THAT FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER WE HAVE THE SPEECH
RECOGNITION SYSTEM THAT MATCHES
A HUMAN PARITY IN TERMS OF HUMAN
ERROR RATE.
THERE'S BEEN A DATA SET IN THE
UNITED STATES CALLED A
SWITCHBOARD DATA SET THAT WAS
INITIALLY SET UP 25 YEARS AGO.
THE HUMAN ERROR RATE IS AROUND
5.1%.
I'M NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
ORDINARY HUMANS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE
PROFESSIONALS WHO DO TRANSCRIPT.
YOU KNOW, WAYS WITH MASSIVE
COMPUTING POWER AND THE
BRILLIANCE OF OUR RESEARCH WITH
HUMAN PARITY OF 5.1%.
IN THE SECOND AREA I WANT TO
TALK TO YOU IS MACHINE READING
COMPREHENSION, OUR NATURAL
LANGUAGE UNDERSTANDING.
LAST YEAR WE ACQUIRED THIS DEEP
LEARNING COMPANY CALLED MALUBA.
THEY DO AMAZING WORK.
THE READING AND WRITING AND
MACHINE READING COMPREHENSION.
YOU WILL SEE MORE ON THE MALUBA
TECHNOLOGIES GET INTO THE
MICROSOFT PRODUCTS IN OFFICE AND
BING AND OTHER PLACES.
THE THIRD AREA IS SCHEDULE
MACHINE TRANSLATION.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING MACHINE
TRANSLATION FOR A LONG TIME IN
OUR RESEARCH LABS.
BUT NOW YOU CAN GET THE MACHINE
TRANSLATION IN MANY, MANY
PRODUCTS.
A FEW YEARS AGO, WE SHIPPED THE
MACHINE TRANSLATION.
WE SHIPPED A MICROSOFT
TRANSLATOR IN iOS LAST YEAR AND
MOBILE APPS.
AND MONTHS AGO, IT WAS GREA
AND MONTHS AGO, IT WAS GR-- WE E
SHIPPING MACHINE TRANSLATOR IN
FLAGSHIP PHONES LIKE MAY 10.
CLEARLY THAT WITH ALL THIS
COMPARISON DATA WE SEE THAT WE
NOW HAVE THE MOST ACCURATE
MACHINE TRANSLATOR OF ANY MOBILE
PHONES TODAY.
THOSE ARE THE EXCITING THINGS,
YOU KNOW, IN -- YOU RESEARCH
WITH THE TECHNOLOGY AND MOVING
TO MAINSTREAM PRODUCTS.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT A.I. AS
WELL AND IF ALL THE DEVELOPERS
COULD USE ALL THOSE COOL
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE IN
MICROSOFT AND FROM OUR LABS,
WHAT IF WE MAKE THEM AVAILABLE
ESPECIALLY THROUGH OUR CLOUD
PLATFORM.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE ONE OF THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE CLOUD PLUS A.I.
PLATFORMS ON THE MARKET.
THERE ARE REALLY THREE PIECES
THAT I WANTED YOU TO UNDERSTAND
AS WE TALK ABOUT A.I. PLATFORMS.
THESE ARE SERVICES THAT WE CAN
OFFER AND INFRASTRUCTURE, A.I.
ON DATA AND A.I. COMPUTE.
AND ALSO TOOLS LIKE VISUAL
STUDIO TOOLS, VISUAL STUDIO
TOOLS FOR A.I. THAT WE RECENTLY
SHIPPED, AND WITH LIMITED TIME
I'M GOING TO MAKE A DEEP DIVE
INTO SOME OF THE SERVICES THAT
WE ARE ALREADY SHIPPING.
FIRST OF ALL, I'D LIKE TO SHARE
THAT MORE THAN 760,000
DEVELOPERS ARE ALREADY USING
MICROSOFT COGNITIVE SERVICES.
THIS IS TO SET UP WEB APIs,
DEVELOPERS CAN TAKE THEM AND
INTO THEIR OWN APPLICATIONS.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE THE MIX OF THE
HEALTH CARES AND HOW THEY USE
MICROSOFT COGNITIVE SERVICES.
AND WE WANT TO HELP EVERY
DEVELOPER TO BECOME AN A.I.
DEVELOPER.
AT MICROSOFT, WE USE COGNITIVE
SERVICES, TOO, TO CREATE A
UNIQUE USER EXPERIENCE.
ONE OF MY FAVORITES IS THIS APP
CALLED THE SEEING A.I.
WE LAUNCHED IT IN JULY.
IT'S AN APP USING COMPUTER
VISION A.I. TECHNOLOGY TO HELP
THE BLIND AND THE VISUALLY
IMPAIRED.
AND IT'S AMAZING TO SEE THAT
MORE THAN 100,000 DOWNLOADS
ALREADY HAPPENED.
IT HAS A READING OF 4.8.
IT'S TOUCHING TO ME HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY CREATE APPS THAT PEOPLE
AGREE ON, AND THERE'S BEEN GREAT
RESPONSE FROM THE COMMUNITY.
TODAY WE HAVE MORE GREAT
FEATURES FOR THE SEEING A.I. APP
SUCH AS CURRENCY RECOGNITION,
LIE DETECTION.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE TIME
AFTER THIS AND STOP BY THE
BOOTHS AND CHECK OUT, AND YOU
WILL LEARN THE DESIGN QUESTIONS
THERE, HOW YOU CAN EVEN TAKE THE
TECHNOLOGY TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
COULDN'T SEE VERY WELL.
MAKES YOU THINK ABOUT THE DESIGN
VERY DIFFERENTLY, LIKE USING
DIFFERENT MODALITIES TO HELP.
THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE.
THE OTHER THING WE FEEL GOOD
ABOUT, WE KNOW IT'S HELPFUL TO
DEVELOPERS IS THAT AMONG ALL
THOSE APIs WE ALREADY SHIPPED,
ONE IS CALLED LANGUAGE
UNDERSTANDING SERVICE.
THAT IS REALLY, REALLY GETTING
VERY, VERY POPULAR.
THE CUSTOMERS LIKE IT, DIXON,
SABRE, HUMANE DIRECT.
WE APPRECIATE THEIR HELP GIVING
US THE FEEDBACK AND HELPING US
TO GET TO CERTAIN QUALITY TODAY.
I'M HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THAT G.A.
IS GENERALLY AVAILABLE.
IT'S VERY, VERY EXCITING.
ANOTHER THING I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT HELPING DEVELOPERS IS WITH
AZURE SERVICES.
YOU KNOW, MANY, MANY COMPANIES,
YOU KNOW, COMPANIES LIKE
PROGRESSIVE, UNILEVER, YOU KNOW,
THEY WANT TO BE THE BOTS AND
APPS TO INTERACT WITH THE
CUSTOMERS, WITH EMPLOYEES, MUCH
LIKE WE TALK JUST LIKE HUMANS.
AND WE OFFER AZURE SERVICE.
AND NOT ONLY TO HELP CREATE THE
BOTS, BUT ALSO HELP YOU TO
DEPLOY THE BOTS AND ALSO HELP
YOU TO RUN THE BOTS.
WE ALREADY HAVE 240,000
DEVELOPERS USING AZURE BOT
SERVICES EVEN IN THE PREVIEW
FORMAT.
TODAY WE'RE ANNOUNCING THAT IT'S
G.A. NOW, SO IT'S VERY EXCITING.
OF COURSE, AS WE DEVELOP A.I.,
WE HAVE TO DRIVE THE CONNECTION
WITH THE A.I. COMMUNITY.
AND TO DEMOCRATIZE A.I. IS NOT
JUST ONE COMPANY'S
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT IT IS REALLY THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY'S RESPONSIBILITY.
I GIVE A FEW EXAMPLES HERE WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING AT MICROSOFT.
THE FIRST EXAMPLE IS THE
INTERMETE MEDEATE PRESENTATION,
ONYX.
AN OPEN NETWORK PROJECT THAT WAS
SPOTTED WITH FACEBOOK IN
SEPTEMBER.
IT'S REALLY AN OPEN-SOURCE
FORMAT THAT ENABLES THOSE A.I.
FRAMEWORKS TO INTEROPERATE WITH
EACH OTHER.
EXAMPLE NUMBER ONE.
THE SECOND EXAMPLE IS WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING WITH AMAZON.
IT IS AN A.I. -- THE FREE
NETWORK INTERFACE, YOU KNOW.
THERE ARE SO MANY A.I.
FRAMEWORKS OUT THERE, AND WE
DON'T WANT DEVELOPERS TO BE
CONFUSED.
WE CAN CHANGE ANY OF THE
FRAMEWORK AND GET HELP FROM
AMAZON AND MICROSOFT TO START
WITH THIS TO BYPASS ALL THE
COMPLEXITY WITHOUT SEPARATING
ANY OF THE SPEECH.
THE THIRD EXAMPLE IS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN MAKING A LOT OF
INVESTMENTS WITH MICROSOFT
VENTURE IN BOTH LEADING A.I.
COMPANIES, EMERGING COMPANIES
THERE.
SOME GREAT EXAMPLES I SHOW HERE
LIKE A.I., THE BANZAI AND
DETECT, THOSE ARE EXCITING
ACTIVITIES THAT WE DO.
ANOTHER THING I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU IS THAT WE SEE THE
VERTICAL SOLUTIONS AND --
THEY'RE VERY, VERY EXCITING.
AND ONE EXAMPLE, WE PUSH HARD AT
MICROSOFT TOGETHER WITH OUR
PARTNERS.
THAT IS THE BUSINESS A.I.
SOLUTIONS FOR CUSTOMER SERVICES.
I'M SURE AT SOME POINT OF YOUR
LIFE YOU USE CUSTOMER SERVICES
AND TYPICALLY, YOU KNOW, YOU USE
CUSTOMER SERVICES, YOU SPEND A
LOT OF TIME, YOU KNOW, AND YOU
STILL GET FRUSTRATED.
THIS IS WHERE A.I. CAN REALLY
COME IN TO HELP.
IMAGINE YOU HAVE A VIRTUAL AGENT
AND AGING ASSISTANTS AND THE
MANAGEMENT TOOL TO BRING THIS
TOGETHER.
WEE GREAT PARTNERS LIKE H.P. AND
MACY'S AND AUSTRALIAN
GOVERNMENT'S DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
SERVICES WORKING WITH US TO
DELIVER THOSE FANTASTIC
SOLUTIONS.
THOSE ARE EXCITING THINGS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DOING AT MICROSOFT
A.I. AND R.
BUT TODAY I WANT TO FOCUS ON
EVERYDAY A.I.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT ARE
THE PRACTICAL WAYS -- WHAT ARE
THE PRODUCTS THAT WE ALREADY ARE
SHIPPING WITH NEW AND COOL A.I.
FEATURES TO HELP EVERYONE EVERY
DAY.
SO LET ME START WITH ONE OF
THOSE MOST PERVASIVE FORMS OF
A.I. CALLED THE SEARCH.
YOU MIGHT SAY, WELL, WHAT'S NEW
IN SEARCH?
I HAVE BEEN USING SEARCH FOR A
LONG TIME.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT SEARCH HAS
MOVED ON, IS NO LONGER JUST TEN
BLUE LINKS.
NOW SEARCH CAN BE SO POWERFUL
WITH THE CONCEPTS, WITH
DIALOGUES WITH MANY MORE THINGS.
AND MICROSOFT WE HAVE VIEWED
BING BEYOND JUST A SEARCH
ENGINE.
BING HAS HELPED TO BUILD THE
MICROSOFT CLOUD SERVICES WITH
ALL THE STRUCTURE.
AND IT'S BECOME THE FOUNDATION
FOR A.I. FOR OUR COMPANY.
AND WE MIGHT BE MUCH BIGGER THAN
YOU EVEN THINK ABOUT.
AND WE LAUNCHED THE BING IN YEAR
2007.
AND IT'S NOW POWERING OVER
ONE-THIRD OF THE P.C. SEARCH WEB
TRAFFIC IN THE UNITED STATES AND
CONTINUES TO GROW IN THE U.S.
AND WORLDWIDE.
IT ALSO POWERS SOME EXPERIENCES
FOR MANY OF OUR PARTNERS
INCLUDING YAHOO!, NOW WITH
VERIZON, L.L., AND AMTRAK, AND
THE MULTILINGUAL ABILITY OF
TWEETER AND APPLE'S RESEARCH.
WE HAVE DEVELOPED FUNDAMENTAL
A.I. TECHNOLOGIES ESPECIALLY IN
NATURAL UNDERSTANDING.
THIS IS REALLY A LOT OF THINGS
THAT WE CAN DEPEND ON FOR THE
FUTURE A.I. DEVELOPMENT.
TODAY I'M VERY, VERY EXCITED TO
INTRODUCE THREE NEW INTELLIGENT
SEARCH CAPABILITIES THAT WE ARE
SHIPPING IMMEDIATELY WITH BING.
FIRST THING IS WHAT WE CALL THE
INTELLIGENT ANSWERS.
THAT UTILIZES THE MACHINE
COMPANY WITH MULTIPLE QUESTIONS,
SNIPPETS OF MULTIPLE ANSWERS
ACROSS MULTIPLE SOURCES AND
TRANSLATES DATA INTO
EASY-TO-UNDERSTAND CONCEPTS.
NOT ONLY DO YOU SEE MORE OF THE
MODEL'S ANSWERS POPPING UP, THE
POPUP SEARCH PAGE FROM BING, BUT
YOU WILL GET A LOT MORE
PERSPECTIVE, AS WELL.
SECOND, INTELLIGENT IMAGE
SEARCH.
THAT ENABLES YOU TO SEARCH IMAGE
WITHIN THE IMAGES BY LEVERAGING
RECOGNITION.
THAT'S ANOTHER COOL WAY TO FIND
WHAT YOU ARE REALLY LOOKING FOR.
THE THIRD NEW FEATURE ABOUT THE
NEW INTELLIGENT SEARCH IN BING
IS WHAT I CALL THE
CONVERSATIONAL SEARCH.
THAT REALLY PROVIDES INTELLIGENT
SUGGESTIONS TO HELP YOU TO FIND
WHAT YOU ARE REALLY LOOKING FOR.
VERY OFTEN WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE
WANT TO SEARCH FOR SOMETHING,
BUT IT'S HARD TO EXPRESS.
WHAT IF WE TURN THE EXPERIENCE
INTO MORE A DIALOGUE?
THAT'S THE THIRD THING CALLED A
CONVERSATIONAL SEARCH.
PLEASE WELCOME CHRISTINA BARED
FROM THE BING TEAM.
CHRISTINA?
>> THANKS, HARRY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> AT THE CENTER OF A.I. IS
DATA.
IT POWERS EVERYTHING.
AT MICROSOFT WE HAVE WORLD
KNOWLEDGE WITH BING AND WORK
KNOWLEDGE WITH THE REST OF THE
MICROSOFT GRAPH.
REALLY THE MAGIC HAPPENS WHEN
YOU MAKE SENSE OF ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION.
WE'VE EVOLVED FROM SIMPLE
SEARCHES AND KEY WORD MATCHING
TO USE ADVANCE A.I. TECHNIQUES
LIKE MACHINE READING
COMPREHENSION THAT USES DEEP
LEARNING TO UNDERSTAND THE
MEANING BEHIND WORDS.
WE ALSO NEED REALLY POWERFUL
HARDWARE IN ORDER TO PROCESS THE
MODELS LIKE DEEP NEURONETWORKS.
WE'VE PARTNERED WITH INTEL TO
PAIR AGILITY AND PERFORMANCE
WITH CHIPS THAT ALLOW US TO READ
AND UNDERSTAND BILLIONS OF
DOCUMENTS IN MILLISECONDS.
SO HOW DOES THIS APPLY TO YOUR
EVERY DAY?
TODAY I'M GOING TO SHOW HOW A.I.
ENABLES INTELLIGENT SEARCH IN A
FEW WAYS.
ONE WITH INTELLIGENT ANSWERS,
BING FOR BUSINESS, INTELLIGENT
IMAGE SEARCH, AND A NEW SEARCH
PARADIGM THAT IS FOR MORE
CONVERSATIONAL SEARCH.
LET'S START WITH SOMETHING
RATHER MUNDANE LIKE FINDING A
MOVIE TO WATCH FOR THE HOLIDAYS.
INSTEAD OF A SIMPLE KEYWORD
SEARCH, I'LL USING SOMETHING
LIKE MOVIES DIRECTED BY
SPIELBERG STARRING TOM HANKS.
LET'S USE TOM HANKS.
THIS ANSWER IS SPECIFIC TO MY
QUERY.
IT FILTERED OUT TV SHOWS AND
PARTNERSHIPS, BUT IT INCLUDED A
MOVIE THEY'RE DOING TOGETHER IN
JANUARY.
WITH BING'S VAST UNDERSTANDING
OF THE WORLD, PEOPLE, AND
ENTITIES AND HOW THEY RELATE TO
EACH OTHER, A.I. ENABLES US TO
POWER MORE RICH AND COMPLETE
ANSWERS.
SAY I'M DOING RESEARCH ON
SOMETHING A BIT MORE
CONTROVERSIAL.
I'M A VEGAN, AND I TAKE A LOT OF
FLACK FROM MY FAMILY FOR BEING
AN ANNOYING KALE PUSHER.
I WANT TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
INEVITABLE HOLIDAY TABLE DEBATE
WITH MY COUSIN.
SO I'M GOING TO DO A SEARCH FOR
FACTS ABOUT KALE.
THIS RESULT HERE IS A
MULTISOURCE ANSWER.
BING USES A.I. TO BRING TOGETHER
INFORMATION FROM MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT WEBSITES INTO ONE
PLACE.
AND AT MICROSOFT, WE BELIEVE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE INFORMATION COMES FROM.
SO ALTHOUGH WE PROVIDE QUICK
ACCESS AND LINKS TO CONTENT,
WE'RE ALSO CAREFUL TO MAKE SURE
WE ALSO INCLUDE SOURCES.
THIS WAY I CAN FEEL CONFIDENT
ABOUT MY ADVOCACY OF KALE.
IF I WANT TO BE SUPER PREPARED
AND UNDERSTAND BOTH SIDES OF AN
ISSUE -- BECAUSE WE DON'T LIVE
IN A WORLD OF ABSOLUTES -- I CAN
DO A QUERY LIKE -- ALSO USING
NATURAL LANGUAGE LIKE IS KALE
GOOD FOR YOU?
THIS IS A MULTIPERSPECTIVE
ANSWER.
BING SHOWS ALTERNATE VIEWPOINTS
SO YOU CAN UNDERSTAND BOTH SIDES
OF AN ISSUE.
ON ONE SIDE I HAVE PRO-KALE.
AND ON THE OTHER SIDE I HAVE A
CAUTIONARY TALE OF WHY TOO MUCH
KALE IS BAD SO THAT I DON'T HAVE
TO LIVE IN A BUBBLE WHERE
EVERYTHING ABOUT KALE IS
AMAZING.
IF I REALLY WANT TO EMBRACE THIS
KALE-LOVING LIFESTYLE, I SHOULD
PROBABLY TAKE UP YOGA OR
PILATES.
I DON'T ACTUALLY REALLY KNOW THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THEM.
SO IF I DO A SEARCH FOR
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN YOGA AND
PILATES, I GET THIS COMPARISON
ANSWER -- BING HAS TAKEN
COMPARISONS, A FEATURE TYPICALLY
FOUND IN PRODUCT OR
SHOPPING-BASED SCENARIOS, AND
HAVE EXPANDED IT TO A WIDER
QUERY SET.
WE USE MACHINE READING
COMPREHENSION TO READ THE WEB
AND UNDERSTAND ENTITIES AND
THEIR ASPECTS IN ORDER TO
COMPARE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
ITEMS.
SO YOGA SEEMS LIKE IT'S MORE MY
JAM.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD AND PICK THAT.
AND I'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT YOGA
RETREATS IN COSTA RICA.
SO -- I DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE A
SENSE FOR HOW BIG IS COSTA RICA?
THIS IS A RELATIONAL ANSWER.
IN ADDITION TO SHOWING THE
ACTUAL SQUARE MILES, I'M ALSO
TOLD IT'S ABOUT TWICE THE SIZE
OF MASSACHUSETTS WHICH IS
INCIDENTALLY MY HOME STATE.
SO I GO A GOOD SENSE OF WHAT
THAT MEANS.
BING HAS TAKEN -- USED A.I. AND
ADDED PERSPECTIVE TO
INFORMATION.
NOT ONLY ARE WE USING A.I. TO
SEACH ACROSS THE BILLIONS OF
DOCUMENTS IN THE WEB, WE'RE ALSO
USING A.I. TO MAKE INFORMATION
MORE UNDERSTANDABLE.
BECAUSE WHILE THE ENGINEER IN ME
GEEKS OUT ON ALL OF THIS DATA,
THE DESIGNER IN ME KNOWS THAT
REAL USER DELIGHT COMES FROM
MAKING DATA MAKE SENSE.
ALL OF THESE NEW EXPERIENCES,
MULTIPLE SOURCES, MULTIPLE
PERSPECTIVES, COMPARISONS, AND
RELATIONAL ANSWERS, THEY ALL
MAKE UP WHAT WE CALL INTELLIGENT
ANSWERS.
SO ALL OF THESE EVERYDAY A.I.
CAPABILITIES ARE AWESOME.
BUT WHAT IF WE COULD APPLY THEM
TO THE CONTEXT OF WORK?
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE DONE
FOR BING FOR BUSINESS.
LET'S GO TO THE BING HOME PAGE.
BECAUSE I'M SIGNED IN WITH MY
MICROSOFT WORK ACCOUNT, AT THE
BOTTOM OF MY HOME PAGE, I CAN
SEE INDUSTRY-RELATED NEWS.
AND THAT'S RELEVANT TO ME, A
PERSON IN TECH.
AND BEYOND THIS PERSONALIZATION,
LET ME SHOW WHAT THE MICROSOFT
GRAPH AND A.I. IS DO FOR A
WORKPLACE PRODUCTIVITY.
I HAVE A MICROSOFT HOLIDAY PARTY
COMING UP, AND THE FABULOUS
HARRY SHUM IS MY EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT.
SO BECAUSE I'M SIGNED IN, AND
BUSINESS ENABLED, I TYPE IN
HARRY'S ORG, AND NOTE THAT I'M
NOT USING HIS LAST NAME.
IT STILL PROVIDES THE ORG CHART
FOR THE RIGHT HARRY EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT HARRYs
THAT WORK AT MICROSOFT.
ALSO, WEB RESULTS RELATED TO THE
QUERY HARRY'S ORG.
BING FOR BUSINESS BRINGS
TOGETHER THE BEST OF CORPORATE
INTERNET SEARCH WITH BEST OF WEB
SEARCH ALL INTO ONE EXPERIENCE.
SO IF I DO SOMETHING A LITTLE
BIT MORE COMPLICATED LIKE HOW
HOW MUCH VACATION DO I GET?
BECAUSE OF THE FPCA CHIP, I GET
ANSWERS IN MILLISECONDS.
IF SOMETHING'S SUPER OBSCURE, I
CAN SEARCH FOR "CAN I HIRE MY
COUSIN"
COUSIN."
AND MACHINE READING POWERS THIS
ANSWER.
WHAT YOU NOTICE IS THAT COUSIN
ISN'T EVEN MENTIONED IN THE
PASSAGE.
THAT'S BECAUSE BING KNOWS THAT
COWS SINCE A FAMILY MEMBER AND
UNDERSTANDS -- COUSIN IS A
FAMILY MEMBER AND UNDERSTANDS
THE MEANING BEHIND WORDS TO GET
ME THE RIGHT ANSWER -- NOT THAT
I WOULD HIRE MY KALE-HATING
COUSIN ANYWAY.
FOR THIS HOLIDAY PARTY, I'M ALSO
GOING TO WANT TO FIND SOMETHING
FESTIVE TO WEAR.
IT IS A WORK EVENT.
I'LL SEARCH FOR WORK APPROPRIATE
HOLIDAY COCKTAIL DRESS.
I'M GOING TO GO TO IMAGE, OUR
IMAGE VERTICAL.
AND THEN THIS ONE LOOKS
APPROPRIATELY FESTIVE.
BING IMAGE USES A.I. TECHNIQUE
TO FIND DRESSES THAT LOOK LIKE
THIS WITH DIRECT LINKS TO BUY.
SO I CAN LOOK AROUND AND DO
PRICE COMPARISONS.
THE OTHER THING IT DOES IS OUR
OBJECT DETECTION ALLOWS ME TO
RESCOPE THIS QUERY ON JUST THIS
NECKLACE SO NOW I CAN FIND
NECKLACES THAT LOOK SIMILAR TO
ONE IN THIS PHOTO, AGAIN WITH
DIRECT LINKS TO BUY.
BING IS AN INTELLIGENT SEARCH
THAT SAVES TIME AND MONEY.
OKAY.
IN ADDITION TO INTELLIGENT
ANSWERS, BING FOR BUSINESS, AND
INTELLIGENT IMAGE SEARCH, WE'RE
ALSO USING A.I. TO MAKE THE
SEARCH BOX ITSELF MORE
CONVERSATIONAL WITH AN
INTERACTIVE GUIDED SEARCH
EXPERIENCE.
WE HEAR A LOT FROM CUSTOMERS
THAT THEY WISH SEARCH COULD JUST
COMPLETE THEIR SENTENCES.
IF I DO A VAGUE SEARCH LIKE I'M
FEELING STRESSED WHICH MAY OR
MAY NOT BE BECAUSE OF THE DEMO,
I GET THIS GUIDED WEB -- SEARCH
FRIENDS.
THE WEB RESULTS YOU EXPECT FROM
A SEARCH ENGINE, I GET OUR
ANSWERS.
BUT THEN UP TOP, WHAT YOU'LL SEE
HERE IS THAT IT PROMPTS FOR
ADDITIONAL QUERY REFINEMENTS.
I CAN GO THROUGH AND PICK STRESS
MANAGEMENT AND THEN BREATHING
EXERCISES, AND THEN I CAN ALSO
KIND OF EXPAND TO SEE MY
PREVIOUS RESULTS.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT HERE IS THAT
SEARCH IS BUILDING UPON THE LAST
SEARCH.
SO IT'S LITTLE BIT MORE
CONVERSATIONAL, MORE
PERSONALIZED.
WE'RE ABLE TO DO WITH THIS, GET
YOU BETTER ANSWERS FASTER.
THIS IS A NEW SEARCH PARADIGM.
OUR EXPERTISE IN CONVERSATIONAL
A.I. WITH OUR BOTS ARE BROUGHT
TOGETHER WITH OUR VAST DATA,
ENABLES BING TO CREATE A NEW
INTERACTIVE SEARCH EXPERIENCE
THAT GETS YOU BETTER ANSWERS
FASTER.
IF I DO ANOTHER EXAMPLE FOR --
LET'S SEE, SEATTLE VERSE, I'M
PROMPTED FOR POPULAR RIVALRIES.
I'M GOING TO SELECT THE RAMS
HERE.
HERE YOU'LL SEE AN ANSWER OF AN
UPCOMING GAME ON THE 17th.
IN ADDITION TO WEB LINKS AND
THIS AWESOME ANSWER, I CAN ALSO
SEE WHO BING PREDICTS TO WIN.
WE'RE PREDICTING THE RAMS WILL
WIN BY 51%.
BING USES SEARCH, SOCIAL, AND
OTHER RELEVANT DATA SIGNALS IN
ORDER TO MAKE PREDICTIONS ON
SPORTS, REALITY TV SHOWS, AND
MORE.
IF I DO ANOTHER REALLY AMBIGUOUS
SEARCH LIKE SET DEFAULT, WITHOUT
ANY CONTEXT OF WHAT DEFAULT I'M
TRYING TO SET, I'M PROMPTED WITH
VERY POPULAR THINGS THAT PEOPLE
ARE SET TO VOTE FOR.
CONVERSATIONAL SEARCH USES
LARGE-SCALE MACHINE LEARNING.
THIS EXPERIENCE IS ONLY GOING TO
GET BETTER OVER TIME.
A.I. LEARNS FROM USER
ENGAGEMENT, SO WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED FOR THE FUTURE OF
CONVERSATIONAL SEARCH.
WHAT I'VE SHOWN YOU TODAY,
INTERCEPT ANSWERS, BING --
INTELLIGENT ANSWERS, BING FOR
BUSINESS, INTELLIGENT IMAGE
SEARCH, AND A NEW CONVERSATIONAL
GUIDED SEARCH IS JUST A SMALL
SAMPLING OF HOW WE ARE USING
A.I. TO CREATE INTELLIGENT
SEARCH.
ALL OF THESE EXPERIENCES ARE
EITHER LIVE TODAY OR STARTING TO
ROLL OUT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
AND LET ME TURN IT BACK OVER TO
HARRY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
CHRISTINA.
I HOPE YOU LIKE THOSE DEMOS.
YOU MAY NOT REALIZE THIS --
PEOPLE REALLY UNDERESTIMATE HOW
MUCH TIME THEY SPEND SEARCHING
FOR THE RIGHT INFORMATION.
EVEN MORE SO, HOW MUCH TIME THEY
ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO SEARCH FOR
WHETHER THIS IS THE RIGHT
INFORMATION.
THIS IS WHERE NATURAL LANGUAGE,
MACHINE UNDERSTANDING LANGUAGE
COMPREHENSION IS SO IMPORTANT,
AND IT'S DOING THE WORK FOR YOU.
AND THERE'S ANOTHER THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS THAT YOU ALSO WANT
TO KNOW THAT AS PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THIS KIND OF INFORMATION,
WHERE IS THE CONVERSATION, TO
ADD CREDIBILITY TO ALL THIS KIND
OF INTERESTING -- ALL THESE KIND
OF INTERESTING TOPICS.
GONE ARE THE DAYS OF THE ENDLESS
LINKS.
TODAY'S SEARCH IS ABOUT THE REAL
ANSWERS, YOU KNOW, REAL
PERSPECTIVES AND THE REAL
CONVERSATIONS.
THAT'S WHY I'M EXCITED TO
ANNOUNCE A NEW PARTNERSHIP WITH
REDDIT.
WE'RE WORKING TO BRING
CONVERSATION AND ANSWERS TO BING
AND TO BRING BING ENTITIES TO
REDDIT.
TO TALK ABOUT THOSE UNIQUE
APPLICATIONS OF A.I. AT THE
INTERSECTION OF SOCIAL NEWS AND
CONVERSATIONS AND THE SEARCH,
LET ME WELCOME ALEXIS OHANIAN,
CO-FOUNDER OF REDDIT.
ALEXISE?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, HARRY,
HOW YOU DOING?
GOOD TO BE HERE.
HELLO, EVERYONE, GOOD DAY.
THERE IS PRETTY EXCITING.
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT, BEFORE
REDDIT WAS THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
INTERNET, IT WAS A FUN LITTLE
PROJECT THAT MY COLLEGE BUDDY
AND I WERE STARTING IN A SMALL,
LITTLE APARTMENT IN REDFORD,
MASSACHUSETTS.
THIS IS BACK IN 2005.
WE JUST GRADUATED.
WE HAD NO IDEA WHAT WE WERE
DOING.
BUT WE KNEW ENOUGH AND HAD
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVED IN US ENOUGH
TO TAKE A CHANCE.
AND REDDIT TODAY NOW HAS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF USERS,
340 MILLION MONTHLY ACTIVE
USERS, AND ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO,
MY CO-FOUNDER AND CEO STEVE CAME
BACK AND WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
BRINGING HIM BACK TO GET THE
COMPANY RESET AND TO START DOING
A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
BASICALLY WE WISHED WE HAD DONE
MAYBE A DECADE AGO.
IT WAS SOLD IN 2006 TO CONDENAST
AND HAS BEEN SHIPPING A TON OF
CODE AND BUILDING PARTNERSHIPS
AND A TEAM, INCLUDING A
FORMIDABLE B.D. TEAM, A COUPLE
OF WHOM ARE HERE, WHO BASICALLY
TOOK A CHANCE ON US A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
B.D. PROCESS, AND SAID WE WANT
TO BE A PART OF THIS.
WE SEE THE POTENTIAL, AND WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING TODAY WITH THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH MICROSOFT IS
ACTUALLY A REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE
OF HOW FAR WE'VE COME IN A SHORT
TIME.
WHILE REDDIT THE WEBSITE IS 12
YEARS OLD, REDDIT, INC., IS ONLY
TWO, THREE YEARS OLD.
WE'RE PROUD TO BE ANNOUNCING
THIS PARTNERSHIP HERE WITH
MICROSOFT AND BING TODAY.
SO GIVING YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
THE BACK STORY.
TOLD YOU ABOUT MYSELF.
I'M CO-FOUNDER OF REDDIT.
AND YOU KNOW, I'VE NEVER REALLY
UNDERSTOOD THE SCALE OF REDDIT
WHEN I KNOW SOUNDS CRAZY.
I'M A CO-FOUNDER, ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL USERS.
BUT I NEVER REALLY UNDERSTOOD
THE SCALE OF REDDIT UNTIL THIS
PARTNERSHIP BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF IT ALL, IT'S
HARD TO UNDERSTAND THE NUMBERS
BEHIND HOW MANY CONVERSATIONS
AND COMMUNITIES EXIST ON THE
REDDIT PLATFORM.
AND LOOK, IF I CAN'T NAVIGATE IT
OR GROCK IT, THEN HEAVEN HELP
EVERYONE ELSE.
AND SO THE LAST 2.5, 3 YEARS
HAVE REALLY BEEN A CAUSE FOR US
TO MAKE REDDIT MORE ACCESSIBLE
TO THE MASSES.
IF YOU HAVEN'T USED THE REDDIT
APP, I ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO SO.
IT'S ONLY A YEAR OLD, IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT.
MY WIFE TAKES CREDIT FOR HAVING
SPARKED IT BECAUSE ONE OF OUR
FIRST CONVERSATIONS WAS HER
CONFESSING TO ME SHE HAD NO IDEA
WHAT REDDIT WAS.
IMMEDIATELY DOING A SEARCH ON
HER PHONE, NOT FINDING AN APP,
AND THINKING I WAS A LIAR.
BUT THAT'S THE WORLD WE LIVE IN
TODAY.
WE LOOK UP APP FIRST.
REDDIT DIDN'T HAVE A MOBILE
PRESENCE, DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A
WEBSITE, NOW WE DO.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THE DESKTOP WHICH YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN UNVEILED AT SUMMIT IS ALSO
GETTING A REDESIGN.
IT WILL LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
IT WILL LOOK MODERN.
EVERY ONE OF THESE IS A STEP IN
GETTING GREAT CONTINENTY FRONT
OF AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE AS
SUCCESSFULLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND THE PARTNERSHIP WITH BING IS
HELPING US DO THAT ON A WHOLE
OTHER LEVEL.
330 MILLION ACTIVE MONTHLY USERS
REDDIT.
10.7 MILLION POST SUBMISSIONS
PER MONTH.
IT'S A VERY ACTIVE USER BASE.
2.8 MILLION COMMENTS PER DAY.
REDDIT IS THE ONE SOCIAL NETWORK
THAT IS NOT ANTI-SOCIAL.
IT'S THE ONE PLACE WHERE YOU'LL
ACTUALLY READ THE COMMENTS FIRST
BEFORE LOOKING AT THE CONTENT
BECAUSE THEY PROVIDE SO MUCH
VALUE.
THE REASON THOSE COMMENTS
PROVIDE SO MUCH VALUE IS BECAUSE
THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
USERS LIKE PROBABLY MANY OF YOU
ALL UP VOTE THE GOOD ONES, DOWN
VOTE THE BAD ONES, AND A
BRILLIANT ALGORITHM STEVE CAME
UP WITH SAYS AS A BRILLIANT
21-YEAR-OLD SORTS THE GOOD ONES
FROM THE BAD.
HOW MANY IN THE ROOM ARE
REDDITERS?
IT'S OKAY IF YOU'RE USING IT
NOW, IT'S OKAY.
I WON'T TAKE IT PERSONALLY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING SO BRAVE AS
YOU'RE WILLING TO OUT YOURSELVES
AS THE LEAST PRODUCTIVE PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM.
THAT IS IMPRESSIVE.
OVER 138,000 ACTIVE COMMUNITIES
FOR WHATEVER YOUR PASSION,
WHATEVER YOUR LOVE, WHETHER IT
IS THE SEATTLE SEAHAWKS OR
WHETHER IT IS SNEAKERS,
HOPEFULLY THERE'S A FEW
SNEAKER-ETTES HERE WHO
APPRECIATE THE OFF-WHITES I'M
WEARING NOW.
THESE ARE THE COMMUNITIES WHOSE
OPINIONS WE CARE ABOUT.
I DON'T CARE WHAT MY FRIENDS
FROM COLLEGE THINK ABOUT SHOES
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TERRIBLE
TASTE.
I CARE ABOUT WHAT THIS COMMUNITY
OF PEOPLE, THIS PEER GROUP THAT
I CARE ABOUT, HINKS.
AND ISN'T THAT HOW WE HUMANS
HAVE WORKED ALL ALONG?
PEOPLE COME TO REDDIT TO SEE
THIS BREADTH OF COMMUNITIES TO
GET ADVICE, FEEDBACK, A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR WORLD AND
THINGS THEY CARE ABOUT.
WHETHER THEY ARE SHOPPING FOR
BEARD CARE PRODUCTS -- YES,
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF BEARD CARE
COMMUNITIES -- IF YOU DON'T LIKE
BEARDS, THAT'S FINE.
THEY'LL GROW ON YOU.
OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S FINE.
MAYBE YOU'RE A NEW PARENT LIKE I
WAS AND REALLY WORRIED BECAUSE
EVERY PARENT EVERY PHOTO I KNOW
PUTS ON THE INTERNET IS PERFEC
AND PRISTINE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
IMAGE WE WANT TO SHOW TO THE
WORLD.
WHEN YOUR KID'S SCREAMING AT
4:00 A.M., YOU'RE NOT THINKING
LET ME TAKE A SELFIE, YOU'RE
THINKING I NEED SOMEONE TO COMES
RATE WITH.
AND THE COMMUNITY ON REDDIT WAS
PERFECT FOR ME.
WHETHER YOU NEED SKIN CARE
ADVICE, RXSKINCAREADDICTION
WOULD HAVE HELPED ME IN MY TEEN
YEARS.
THERE WAS NO PLACE TO GO FOR
STUFF BECAUSE THESE ARE
CONVERSATIONS PEOPLE CAN ONLY
HAVE ON A PLATFORM LIKE REDDIT
WITH THAT SCALE.
THE INFORMATION IS SITTING
THERE.
SO ENGAGING, WE AVERAGE ABOUT 12
MINUTES PER SESSION.-
THIS ES PER SESSION.-
SO ENGAGING, WE AVERAGE ABOUT 12
THIS IS PER SESSION.-
THIS IS HIGHLYSSION.-
SO ENGAGING, WE AVERAGE ABOUT 12
THIS IS HIGHLY SION.-
THIS IS HIGHLY ENGAGED.
BUT AS LONG AS IT IS JUST ON
REDDIT, WE KNOW WE'RE MISSING
OUT ON A BROADER AUDIENCE THAT
WE KNW CAN BENEFIT FROM IT.
HOW DO WE FIND PARTNERS THAT CAN
GET US TO A MASSIVE AUDIENCE AND
MAINSTREAM REACH?
BING, THERE YOU GO.
THE PARTNERSHIP WITH MICROSOFT
IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
WE'VE GOT THREE BIG THINGS
AROUND THE INTELLIGENT SEARCH
EXPERIENCE THAT WE'RE UNVEILING
TODAY.
AS I'VE TOLD EVERYONE HERE, THIS
IS JUST THE START.
THREE BIG THINGS THAT WILL
INTEGRATE REDDIT CONTENT MORE
DIRECTLY, MORE BEAUTIFULLY MORE
HELPFULLY INTO BIG SEARCH
RESULTS.
THE FIRST OF WHICH ASK MY
ANYTHINGS.
THIS BRAND IS PROBABLY AS WELL
KNOWN AS REDDIT ITSELF.
MANY PLATFORMS HAVE TRIED TO
COPY THE MODEL, BUT THEY'VE ALL
FAILED.
THE MAGIC IS IN THE CONTEXT.
A CROWD-SOURCED Q&A ON ITS
SURFACE DOESN'T SEEM REALLY
INTERESTING UNTIL YOU PUT IT IN
THE CONTEXT OF A COMMUNITY.
AND UNTIL YOU SEE THE SCIENCE
COMMUNITY TALK TO AN EXPERT LIKE
JANE GOODALL AND ASK THEIR MOST
BRILLIANT QUESTIONS.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE
CELEBRITIES.
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR AMAs OF
ALL TIME WAS A VACUUM REPAIRMAN.
HE CAME BACK ON RECENTLY.
HE'S NOW A VACUUM REPAIR
MANAGER.
HE GOT A PROMOTION IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
THAT'S NOT A JOKE.
I'M SERIOUS.
AND IT MAY BE IN NO SMALL PART
THANKS TO THE REDDIT AMA.
HE SPENT 24 HOURS ANSWERING
EVERY QUESTION A PERSON COULD
POST ABOUT A VACUUM.
AND BELIEVE ME, THERE ARE A LOT
OF FASCINATING QUESTIONS ABOUT
VACUUMS FROM WHAT'S THE WEIRDEST
THING YOU'VE FOUND TO I HAVE
THIS PARTICULAR MODEL AND IT
MAKES THIS WHIR-WHIR-WHIR NOISE
EVERY 30 SECONDS.
THESE ARE CONVERSATIONS YOU
WON'T FIND ANYWHERE ELSE BUT ARE
VALUABLE AND NUANCED AND
SPECIAL, AND WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE, WHETHER THEY KNOW IT
OR NOT, WHO HAVE SEARCHING FOR
THIS EVER EVERYDAY ON BING, BUT
NOW WE'RE PROVIDING A
WORLD-CLASS EXPERIENCE TO FIND
IT.
REDDIT CONTENT ITSELF AS WELL AS
THE RESPONSES AROUND A BING
USER'S QUESTION.
THIS IS FUN.
WE'RE SEEING MORE AND MORE
QUERIES NOW PHRASED AS
QUESTIONS.
PART OF THAT'S THE RISE OF
VOICE.
PART OF THAT IS THE FACT THAT
LIKE WE'RE GETTING USED TO
TALKING TO THE ROBOT AND
EXPECTING A GOOD ANSWER.
THE CHALLENGE IS THERE'S A LOT
OF NUANCE WHEN YOU'RE ASKING
OPEN-ENDED QUESTIONS.
REDDIT IS THE LARGEST DATA SET
IN THE ENGLISH-SPEAKING WORLDS
OF VETTED -- WORLD OF VETTED,
NUANCED RESPONSES.
THE GREATEST NFL PLAY IS A VERY
DIFFERENT ANSWER DEPENDING ON
WHETHER YOU'RE ASKING IT IN NEW
ENGLAND OR IN SEATTLE.
THE NFL FANS KNOW WHO WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
SO WHAT IS SO, SO IMPORTANT HERE
IS THAT WE HAVE THIS DATA SET --
WE'VE HAD IT ACTUALLY FOR A LONG
TIME, AND IT GETS BIGGER AND
BIGGER EVERY DAY.
BUT WE OURSELVES ARE STILL
BUILDING A DATA TEAM INSIDE
REDDIT TO UNDERSTAND THE THINGS
WE NEEDED TO KNOW ABOUT.
WE NEEDED PARTNERS TO DO THE
HEAVY LIFTING AROUND DATA
INTELLIGENCE, AND IT CAME BACK
TO MICROSOFT.
THE THIRD THING, MAKING REDDIT
KMURNT
KMU
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR TOP
CONTENT, SUB-REDDITS, MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO A USER WHO RUNS
THE BING REQUIRY, FINDS RESULTS,
AND WHETHER THEY'RE LIKING FOR
CUTE ANIMAL -- THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR CUTE ANIMAL PHOTOS OR A
RECIPE, THEY FIND A VISUAL LOOK
INTO THE COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE WHO VISIT
REDDIT WHO MAY NOT EVEN BE FULLY
AWARE OF HOW MUCH IS BENEATH THE
SURFACE.
HAVING SEARCH RESULTS BE OBVIOUS
AND BEAUTIFUL AND VISUAL IS ONE
MORE STEP TO GETTING THEM AWARE
OF IT.
WE WANTED TO HELP PEOPLE FIND
GREAT CONTENT ON REDDIT.
BING HAS BEEN A GREAT PARTNER IN
DOING THIS.
AMAs ARE SUCH -- THEY WERE SUCH
LOW-HANGING FRUITS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S NEVER
BEEN DONE BEFORE THAT WE'RE
THRILLED TO BE ANNOUNCING HERE,
IS NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
BING SEARCH RESULTS, YOU WILL
SEE UPCOMING AMAINGS.
THIS SEEMS OBVIOUS, BUT IT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE NEVER DONE
BEFORE.
A COMMON COMPLAINT WE HEAR FROM
PEOPLE IS OH, MY GOODNESS, HOW
DID I MISS FILL IN THE BLANK WAS
DOING THIS AMA?
IT'S TOUGH.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW IN ADVANCE,
MAYBE YOU FIND OUT WHILE IT'S
GOING ON, OR MAYBE YOU READ
ABOUT IT A DAY LATER ON YOUR
FRIEND'S FACEBOOK PAGE, MAYBE
YOU READ ABOUT IT A WEEKBUZZFEE.
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER, YOU WISH YOU
HAD KNOWN IN ADVANCE.
IT'S EXCITING.
WE CAN HAVE THIS AS PARITY OF
THE SEARCH RESULTS.
LEAH REMINI HAS DONE A COUPLE OF
AMAs AROUND HER DOCUMENTARY ON
A&E AROUND SCIENTOLOGY.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE, "Q&A WITH
LEAH REMINI," UPCOMING DATE AND
TIME.
SOMEONE PULLS A QUERY BECAUSE
THEY HEARD SOMETHING ABOUT HER
OR HER SERIES, THEY KNOW THIS
EVENT IS HAPPENING, THEY CAN SET
THE ALARM AND DO WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE PART
OF THIS MOMENT.
THIS IS A TRANSFORMATIVE THING
FOR US.
WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE WHO FIND
THEIR GATEWAYS TO REDDIT THROUGH
THESE AMAs, BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD OF REDDIT, YOU'VE
HEARD OF THAT CELEBRITY OR
INFLUENCER OR MAYBE YOU ALSO OWN
A VACUUM THAT YOU WANT TO LEARN
FROM AND HEAR FROM, AND THIS
BECOMES A GREAT GATEWAY.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF A PAST
AMA, IN CASE YOU'RE TRYING TO
SET YOUR CALENDAR, IT'S NOT
GOING TO WORK BECAUSE IT WAS
NOVEMBER 29th.
BUT THAT'S HOW IT WILL LOOK.
THERE'S THE LEVELING UP OF HOW
PAST AMAs LOOKED.
JANE GOODALL DID AN AMAZING JOB
ON REDDIT GETTING ASKED
QUESTIONS THAT ARE THE BEST OF
AN AUDIENCE THAT IS VERY
INTERESTED IN SCIENCE.
YOU COULD CUT THIS A BUNCH OF
WAYS.
WE SAY AMAs HAPPENING ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES ON REDDIT.
THE QUESTIONS SHE'LL GET ARE
DIFFERENT, MORE NUANCED, THAN
THE QUESTIONS SHE GETS FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT COMMUNITY WHICH ARE
DIFFERENT FROM THE QUESTIONS SHE
MIGHT GET FROM THE 2X
CHROMOSOMES COMMUNITY WHICH ARE
DIFFERENT FROM THE QUESTIONS SHE
MIGHT GET FROM THE ET CETERA, ET
CETERA COMMUNITIES.
BING CAN HANDLE ALL OF THIS.
AND THROUGH ROBOTS THAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND AND CERTAINLY WOULD
NOT CHALLENGE IN A GAME OF
CHESS, FIGURE OUT WHAT THE BEST
RESULTS SHOULD BE AND PRESENT
THEM IN A WYE THAT'S DIGESTIBLE
AND -- IN A WAY THAT'S
DIGESTIBLE AND ACCESSIBLE FOR
USERS.
THE TOP COMMENT, TOP RESPONSE.
BELIEVE ME, I'VE HEARD A FEW
TIMES AT THAT CURRENT DESKTOP
VERSION OF REDDIT IS HARD TO
GROCK AT FIRST GLANCE.
THESE BEAUTIFUL RESULTS LET
SOMEONE RUNNING A QUERY FIND THE
BING CONTENT, DIVE IN INSTANTLY,
AND SEE THE BEST OF WHAT THE
RIDITY COMMUNITY HAS TO OFFER --
REDDIT COMMUNITY HAS TO OFFER
AND WHAT JANE GOODALL AND THE
EXPERTS HAVE TO OFFER.
THESE ARE THE BEST AMAs OF ALL
TIME.
I ADMIT, I MISS GOOD HALF OF
THESE.
IT'S BEEN A BUSY YEAR.
NOW THEY EXIST WITH BEAUTIFUL
THUMBNAILS UP TOP FOR ANYONE TO
SEE.
THIS IS MORE ACCESSIBILITY INTO
THE RICH CONTENT WE KNOW IS
THERE BUT ISN'T ALWAYS THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL.
THIS IS PART OF A BIGGER
ROLLOUT.
THAT AIR SELL WILL CONTINUE TO
-- CAROUSEL WILL CONTINUE TO
UPDATE.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO SEE THE BEST
OF THESE Q&A RESULTS, REDDIT
CONVERSATIONS THAT BUBBLE UP TO
THE TOP.
SO CONVERSATIONS ARE
INTERESTING.
LIKE I SAID, REDDIT'S THE ONE
PLACE WHERE CONVERSATION HAPPENS
ON LINE AND WHERE THE BEST STUFF
AS DETERMINED BY THAT COMMUNITY
BUBBLES UP.
THIS HAS BEEN FUN FOR ME BECAUSE
I'VE REVISITED MOMENTS AND TIMES
IN MY LIFE THAT I DIDN'T I THINK
I WOULD EVER AGAIN THANKS TO
REDDIT.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF USERS ACROSS
100,000-PLUS COMMUNITIES.
THEY UNDERSTAND NUANCE BECAUSE
IT'S A HUMAN ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS AND ASKING IT.
THIS IS GREAT DATA FOR THE BING
TEAM TO LEARN WHAT REALLY THE
BEST ANSWERS ARE FOR QUESTIONS
THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE EASIEST
FOR A ROBOT.
FOR INSTANCE, HOW ACCURATE IS
HBO'S "BAND OF BROTHERS"?
THIS WAS TOTALLY SERENDIPITOUS.
WHEN THE TEAM PRESENTED THIS, I
GOT EXCITED.
"BAND OF BROTHERS" WAS THE SHOW
THAT STEVE AND I WOULD BINGE ON
WHILE WE WERE BUILDING REDDIT.
AND WE'D AT THE END OF A LONG
DAY, WE'D GET ON TOP OF THE ROOF
IN SOMERVILLE AND CRACK OPEN A
COUPLE OF BEERS AND WATCH "BAND
OF BROTHERS."
WE OBSESSED OVER THE SERIES.
IT'S A REALLY WELL-DONE SERIES.
I WAS A HISTORY MAJOR, BELIEVE
IT OR NOT.
I STUDIED EUROPEAN DEGREE.
WITH THE DEGREE, I STILL HAD
QUESTIONS WATCHING THIS.
AND WHEN I DIVE ON TO THE ASK
HISTORIANS COMMUNITY ON REDDIT,
I ACTUALLY HAVE A WINDOW INTO
THE VERY BEST HISTORIANS,
HISTORY STUDENTS, MAYBE ARMCHAIR
HISTORIANS IMAGINABLE BECAUSE
THIS COMMUNITY ACTUALLY
SELF-CURATES.
THEY REQUIRE CITATION FOR POSTS.
AND THEY CAN PROVIDE A REALLY
VALUABLE INSIGHT ON A SUBJECT
MATTER THAT HAS SHADES OF
NUANCE.
A QUESTION LIKE HOW ACCURATE IS
"BAND OF BROTHERS" IS NOT A
SIMPLE, BINARY YES, RIGHT?
IT'S, WELL, YEAH, IN A LOT OF
WAYS IT IS.
HERE'S WHAT THEY GOT RIGHT,
HERE'S WHAT THEY GOT WRONG, HERE
ARE THINGS THAT ARE DISPUTED,
AND HERE ARE TWO POINTS OF VIEW.
AS HUMANS, WE LOVE THIS --
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LIKE HISTORY.
WE GET TO DIG INTO THIS BECAUSE
THERE ARE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES.
ROBOTS DON'T WORK SO WELL WITH
THE NUANCE UNLESS THEY HAVE THIS
DATA.
NOW WE'RE SEEING RESULTS THAT
ARE HELPFUL AND VALUABLE.
YOU SEE TRENDING COMMENTS.
LOOK, IT'S LIKE I AM TRANSPORTED
BACK TO THOSE HISTORY CLASSES IN
SCHOOL WITH THE VERY BEST IDEAS
BEING VOTED UP.
WE'RE SEEING THE SAME THING EVEN
AROUND THINGS THAT MAY SEEM
OBVIOUS LIKE WHY MY POT ISN'T
BOILING WITH WATER.
NOW LOOK, I KNOW IF YOU WATCH
IT, TECHNICAL AT THE'S NOT
SUPPOSED.
TO -- TECHNICALLY IT'S NOT
TO TURNS OUT THAT'S SCIENTIFIC
FACT.
IF YOU HAVE TRIED, LIKE I HAVE,
TO BOIL ONE OF THOSE HUGE -- I
WAS DOING A CRAWFISH BOIMP YOU
NAIL WITH WATER AND PUT IT ON
HIGH, AND YOU WILL FIND IT TAKES
A REALLY LONG TIME.
THERE WAS A COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE
FRUSTRATED, WONDERING, AND
ASKING BING FOR AN ANSWER TO
THIS.
NOW THEY CAN GET REALLY HELPFUL
RESULTS.
THEY CAN GET UNDERSTANDING FROM
A CHEMIST'S POINT OF VIEW AND
FROM A CHEF'S POINT OF VIEW AND
MAYBE TRICKS TO HELP SOLVE THAT
LITTLE BOILING PROBLEM.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT PRESENTING
THAT GREAT CONTENT IN A MUCH
MORE ACCESSIBLE WAY TO BING
USERS WHO MAY OR MAY NOT EVEN BE
AWARE OF REDDIT WHEN THEY'RE
RUNNING THE QUERY BECAUSE WE
KNOW THE CONTENT IS RAUBL
KNOW THE CONTENT IS RAVALUABLE.
WE SEE THIS AS A WINDOW INTO,
FRANKLY, HELP PEOPLE DISCOVER
COMMUNITIES THEY DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THEY WANTED TO BE A PART
OF.
THEY DIDN'T EACH KNOW THEY WERE
INTO.
-- THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THEY
WERE INTO.
130,000 COMMUNITIES MEANS A TON
OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO FIND
THINGS YOU LOVE ON REDDIT.
IT'S ABOUT CUTE ANIMALS
SOMETIMES.
THIS IS A WINDOW INTO THE AWW
COMMUNITY, ONE OF OUR LARGEST,
FEATURING PHOTOS OF CATS, DOGS,
AND OTHER ANIMALS.
NOW WITH THIS WONDERFUL
FIRST-CLASS TREATMENT, WHEN YOU
SEE THE RESULTS, YOU SEE A
WINDOW IN.
YOU SEE THE VOTES, YOU SEE THE
COMMENTS, YOU SEE BEAUTIFUL
THUMBNAILS.
YOU ARE INVITED INTO A COMMUNITY
NOW IN A WAY THAT IS PROBABLY
NEW TO A LOT OF INTERNET USERS.
WE'RE SO USED TO A ONE-WAY
CONVERSATION.
NOW WE'RE EXPOSING THEM TO THE
MAGIC OF REAL CONVERSATION ON
REDDIT.
MAYBE YOU WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
CONFUSED OTHERWISE.
DATA IS BEAUTIFUL.
ON THE SURFACE SEEMS LIKE A
COMMUNITY ALL ABOUT SAYING HOW
ATTRACTIVE THE ANDROID FROM
"STAR TREK" IS, AND YOU GRAMMAR
AFICIONADOS KNOW IT'S ARE
BEAUTIFUL BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
KNIT PICK.
IT'S THE LARGEST COMMUNITY OF
DATA VISUALIZATION AND STATS
FANS.
ALL THEY DO IS SHARE DATA SETS
AND VISUALIZATIONS ALL THE TIME.
A FABULOUS COMMUNITY.
NOW IT'S SHOWING UP IN CONTEXT
IN A BEAUTIFUL WAY TO SEE WHAT
THE TRENDING ASPECTS AND
TRENDING DISCUSSIONS ARE ON THE
COMMUNITY AND DIRECTLY LINK TO
REDDIT POSTS.
LIKE I SAID, THIS IS MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL.
IT'S HELPING BRING A WHOLE NEW
EVEN BROADER SWATH OF INTERNET
USERS ON TO REDDIT IN A USEFUL,
ACCESSIBLE, BEAUTIFUL WAY, AND
THEN IT'S GOING TO POWER BING
SEARCH RESULTS SO THOSE TON GET
BETTER OVER TIME USING DATA THAT
ONLY REDDIT HAS.
AND THAT'S THANKS TO A LOT OF
YOU, THANKS TO YOUR COMMENTS AND
UP VOTES.
WE KNOW THIS, SO WE CAN SHARE IT
AND MAKE PLATFORMS BETTER AS A
RESULT.
LIKE I SAID FROM JUMP THIS IS
JUST THE START, REDDIT MAY BE 12
YEARS OLD ON THE INTERNET, BUT
IT'S REALLY ONLY A FEW YEARS OLD
AS A BUSINESS.
THE GROWTH AND THE GREAT, GREAT
SUCCESS WE'VE HAD IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
THIS PARTNERSHIP IS LIKE A CROWN
JEWEL FOR US.
WE KNOW WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO, AND WE HAVE BIG
AMBITIONS.
THIS SCRATCHES THE SURFACE ON
OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH MICROSOFT
A.I. AND REDDIT DATA.
WE'RE ALSO LAUNCHING TODAY HERE
POWER BI.
I'VE HAD TO TALK TO CMOs ALL
OVER, FORTUNE 100 COMPANIES, WHO
HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR A CRYSTAL
BALL.
WOULDN'T WE ALL LIKE THAT, TO BE
ABLE TO GET IN FRONT OF THE
WATER COOLER WHERE THE
CONVERSATIONS, THE REAL
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING
AMONG THE PEOPLE WHO WE CARE
MOST ABOUT, ABOUT THE THINGS WE
CARE MOST ABOUT.
AND REDDIT IS THE PLACE.
WHETHER YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT
THE TRENDING SNEAKERS ARE BEFORE
ANYONE ELSE -- I'VE HAD
COUNTLESS PEOPLE COME UP TO ME
AND JUST THANK ME.
I'VE ASKED THEM WHY, AND THEY
SAID R/BITCOIN.
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE IT'S BECAUSE
SIX YEARS AGO THEY WERE ON THAT
COMMUNITY SEEING THE INERTIA,
THE TRACTION, BUYING AT AVERAGE
SHARE OF BITCOIN AT A WAY
CHEAPER PRICE THAN IT IS TODAY
AND HAVE BENEFITED TREMENDOUSLY.
WHETHER YOU WANT TO KNOW THE
KRENDS FOR CRYPTO CURRENCY OR
WHAT MAKE-UP PEOPLE ARE HOT FOR,
YOU WILL FIND IT ON REDDIT
FIRST.
HISTORICALLY, IT'S BEEN HARD.
YOU HAD TO SPEND LOTS OF TIMES
ON THE COMMUNITY, BEING ON THE
PLATFORM.
THANKS TO THIS, WE HAVE THE
BUSINESS INTELLIGENCE MODELS TO
DO THE WORK FOR YOU.
THE ROBOTS ARE DOING THE HARD
STUFF.
THE TRENDS THAT YOU WANT TO
TRACK, THE KEYWORDS THAT YOU
WANT TO FOLLOW, ANY OF THE BRAND
INSIGHTS YOU WANT TO MONITOR,
WE'RE LETTING THE ROBOTS DO THAT
WORK.
WE WANT ALL OF THESE PEOPLE TO
GET THIS DATA SO THAT WE CAN
GIVE THEM A CRYSTAL BALL.
TURNS OUT IT'S BEEN ON REDDIT
FOR A WHILE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL NOW TO HAVE
MICROSOFT TO HELP US BRING IT TO
LIFE, TO HELP US BUILD THE
CRYSTAL BALL.
AND WE WERE LUCKY, TOO.
ALEX RICKAMINI AND NORM CADORI,
HEAD OF BUSINESS PARTNERSHIPS,
ARE HERE.
WE HAVE A COOL BOOTH AROUND THE
CORNER.
YOU CAN TALK TO THEM, ASK
ANYTHING REGARDING POWER BI OR
ANY OF THE STUFF WE'VE ANNOUNCED
TO.
AGAIN, I CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH
THIS IS JUST THE START.
AND THIS HAS BEEN AN EXCITING
TWO, THREE YEARS SINCE COMING
BACK.
THE NEXT TWO OR THREE WILL BE
EVEN MORE AMAZING.
I'M GRATEFUL TO MICROSOFT FOR
HELPING BE SUCH WONDERFUL
PARTNERS IN THIS JOURNEY.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IT'S AN EXCITING PARTNERSHIP.
I COULDN'T THINK ABOUT IT ANY
BETTER IN PARTNERSHIPS, IMAGINE
WHAT WE CAN DO TOGETHER WITH 330
MILLION REDDIT USERS AND THE 450
MILLION BING USERS WORLDWIDE.
IT'S AMAZING THAT WE CAN REALLY
USE A.I. TO TRANSFORM NOT ONLY
THE SEARCH EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO
THE WEB COMMUNITY CAN ALL WORK
TOGETHER.
I HOPE YOU WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
REALLY TRY THIS NEW BING
EXPERIENCE WITH ALL THE
INTELLIGENCE ANSWERS AND
PERSPECTIVES AND CONVERSATIONS.
THIS IS A NEW NORM, AS YOU THINK
ABOUT THE NEW USER SEARCH
EXPERIENCE.
I WANT TO SWITCH GEARS A LITTLE
BIT.
TALKING ABOUT ANOTHER PLACE
WHERE INTELLIGENCE WILL COME UP.
THAT IS REALLY INTELLIGENT
DIGITAL ASSISTANCE, CORE TAN AMP
I'M SURE BY -- CORTANA.
I'M SURE BY NOW YOU HAVE HEARD
OF INTELLIGENT ASSISTANTS
POPPING UP FROM MANY, MANY
COMPANIES.
YOU DEFINITELY HAVE A QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT'S SO UNIQUE ABOUT THE
MICROSOFT CORTANA.
I TELL YOU TWO THINGS ABOUT THE
MICROSOFT CORTANA THAT'S REALLY
UNIQUE.
NUMBER ONE, CORTANA IS REALLY
DESIGNED FOR YOU TO GO ACROSS
YOUR WORK AND LIFE.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT, THE
LINES BETWEEN WORK AND LIFE ARE
BLURRY.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THE E-MAIL ACCOUNTS THAT YOU USE
AT HOME AND WORK.
THIS IS WHY WE DESIGNED CORTANA
TO BECOME THE BEST ASSISTANT TO
GET THINGS DONE, WHETHER YOU'RE
AT HOME, AT WORK,OR ON TH
AT HOME, AT WORK,OR O OR ON THEO
GET THINGS DONE, WHETHER YOU'RE
AT HOME, AT WORK,OR O OR ON THE.
AND CORTANA WILL HELP YOU FIND
THE EMAILS AND REMIND YOU YOUR
COMMITMENTS YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE ALREADY FORGOTTEN.
AND IT WILL SHARE MEETING TIMES
ON SHARED ACCOUNTS.
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE ACTUALLY NOW
THE SUPPORT TO REALLY HAVE --
HELP YOU TO WORK ACROSS
DIFFERENT E-MAIL SYSTEMS.
SO WE ACTUALLY NOW CAN WORK, YOU
KNOW, AT -- LOOK AT, YOU KNOW,
GMAIL SUPPORT FOR CALENDAR AND
E-MAIL SO CORTANA CAN HELP YOU
GET ACROSS MULTIPLE E-MAIL
SYSTEMS.
I'M VERY HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THAT
WE HAVE THIS ABILITY TODAY.
YOU KNOW, IN CORTANA, YOU WILL
SEE A DEMO SOON.
THE SECOND THING UNIQUE ABOUT
CORTANA I WANT TO SHARE THAT
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT OUR OWN
CORTANA DEVICES ONLY.
WE WANT TO BRING CORTANA TO AS
MANY DEVICES AS POSSIBLE.
AND WE, FOR EXAMPLE, LAUNCHED
THIS SPEAKER RECENTLY WITH A
BEAUTIFUL VOICE QUALITY AND ALL
THE DIGITAL ASSISTANT QUALITY
AND EASY EXPERIENCE.
AND WE ALSO ANNOUNCED THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN CORTANA AND
ALEXA WITH AMAZON.
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE OFFER IN
A UNIQUE USER EXPERIENCE A
INTEREST CROSS WORK IN THE LIFE
ON DIFFERENT DEVICES.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
WE ALSO WANT TO SHOW WHAT IS
MICROSOFT'S OWN WINDOWS AND
OFFICE AND OTHERS AND ALL THE
iOS APPLICATIONS BEING ON THE
PLATFORMS.
THERE IS WHY I'M EXCITED TO
ANNOUNCE TWO NEW MOBILE LAWN
CHAIRS ON THE PLATFORM.
OUR OWN MICROSOFT LAUNCHER AND
CHEETAH MOBILE, YOU KNOW, THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE ONE OF THOSE TOP
PRODUCTIVITY LAUNCHERS IN ENJOY
GOOGLE PLAY STORE.
AND THE CHEETAH MOBILE'S
LAUNCHER WILL BE AVAILABLE
IMMEDIATELY WITH OUR CORTANA
EMBEDDED, AND THE MICROSOFT
LAUNCHER WILL HAVE CORTANA
CAPABILITY IN A COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
THIS INTEGRATION WITH CORTANA IS
REALLY -- WE DO THAT TO HELP
PEOPLE ACROSS MULTIPLE
PLATFORMS.
IT'S REALLY COMING BACK TO MY
EARLY POINT -- YOU THINK ABOUT
WORKING AND THE LINES WHERE YOU
NEED THE ASSISTANT.
THIS IS REALLY OUR COMMITMENT TO
HELP PEOPLE TO GET THINGS DONE
EVEN FASTER.
ONE THING I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYONE IS THAT AS WE DESIGN
THOSE DIGITAL ASSISTANTS LIKE
CORTANA, IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE
CONVERSATIONAL A.I.
IT'S REALLY NOT JUST ABOUT YOU
HAVE ONE QUESTION AND YOU GET AN
ANSWER, THEN YOU GET OUT OF
THERE.
IT'S REALLY ENCOURAGING YOU TO
GET INTO THE DIALOGUE.
I'LL INVITE CHRISTINA TO COME UP
AND SHOW THE INTERESTING CORTANA
DEMOS.
CHRISTINA?
>> THANKS, HARRY.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, CORTANA IS A
FANTASTIC WORKPLACE PRODUCTIVITY
ASSISTANT.
IT CAN HELP WITH THINGS THAT
NORMALLY TAKE A LOT OF TIME AND
A LOT OF STEPS.
ONE EXAMPLE IS FINDING TIME WITH
MY VERY BUSY VP JODI.
HEY, CORTANA, SET UP A MEETING
CALLED F.Y. '18 GOALS WITH JORDI
RIVAS.
>> LOOKS LIKE YOU AND JORDI ARE
BOTH FREE AT 9:30 A.M. ON
JANUARY 8th.
WHEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO MEET?
>> 9:30 A.M. ON JANUARY 8th.
>> OKAY, I'VE SCHEDULED '18
GOALS FOR YOU AND JORDI AT 9:30
A.M. ON MONDAY, JANUARY 8th.
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> GOT IT.
JANUARY -- I TOLD YOU HE WAS
BUSY.
BEFORE TODAY I WOULD HAVE WASTED
A LOT OF TIME GOING BACK AND
FORTH TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHEN
WE WERE BOTH FREE.
NOW WITH CORTANA BECAUSE IT
UNDERSTANDS MY CALENDAR AND
JORDI'S CALENDAR, IT CAN SUGGEST
THE TIME THAT'S BEST FOR BOTH OF
US.
BEYOND A PURE WORKPLACE
PRODUCTIVITY ASSISTANT, WE ALL
KNOW, AS HARRY SAID, THAT THE
LINE BETWEEN WARNING AND HOME,
THEY'RE BLURRING MORE AND MORE
EACH DAY.
THE REAL VALUE IN CORTANA IS
MOVING ACROSS DEVICES AND
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF OUR LIVES.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO SCHEDULE A
WORK TRIP IF YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S ON YOUR PERSONAL
CALENDAR.
WE ALL KNOW THAT SOMETIMES THE
MOST URGENT E-MAIL YOU RECEIVE
DURING A WORKDAY IS FROM A
FAMILY MEMBER OR FRIEND.
CORTANA SUMMARIZES ACROSS YOUR
DIFFERENT E-MAIL ACCOUNTS.
HEY, CORTANA, WHAT NEW E-MAILS
DO I HAVE?
>> YOU'VE GOT SIX NEW EMAILS IN
THE LAST HOUR.
ONE FROM ADAM KIRK MARKED
IMPORTANT.
THREE FROM ANNA WILLIAMS AND TWO
FROM JORDI RIBAS.
WHICH CENTER DO YOU WANT TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT?
>> ADAM, PLEASE.
>> ADAM KIRK E-MAILED YOU ABOUT
CIRQUE DREAMS HOLIDAYS, MARKED
IMPORTANT WANT WANT TO HEAR IT?
>> YES, PLEASE.
>> IT SAYS, "DON'T FORGET TO BY
CIRQUE TICKETS FOR YOUR PARENTS'
VISIT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT A
FRIDAY?
XO, ME."
WHAT SHOULD I DO WITH THIS?
REPLY OR NOTHING?
>> NOTHING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE ALL REALLY BUSY PEOPLE.
BECAUSE CORTANA BLENDS WORK AND
PERSONAL LIFE, I CAN TAKE CARE
OF THINGS AS THEY COME UP.
OF COURSE, I COULD SET A
REMINDER AND TAKE CARE OF THIS
LATER, BUT THERE IS NO TIME LIKE
THE PRESENT.
PROBLEM IS I DON'T EXACTLY KNOW
WHEN MY PARENTS ARE COMING TO
TOWN.
HEY, CORTANA, FIND MOM AND DAD
ON MY CALENDAR.
>> YOU HAVE MOM AND DAD VISITING
AT SEATTLE FROM WEDNESDAY,
DECEMBER 20th, TO WEDNESDAY,
DECEMBER 27th.
>> OKAY.
BECAUSE CORTANA IS ABOUT HELPING
YOU WHEREVER YOU ARE, IT
SUPPORTS INTEGRATION ACROSS
CALENDARS WITH OFFICE 365,
OUTLOOK, AND NEW EVEN GMAIL.
HEY, CORTANA, HELP ME FIND
TICKETS TO CIRQUE DREAMS
HOLIDAYS IN SEATTLE ON DECEMBER
22nd.
>> I HAVE THREE SKILLS THAT CAN
HELP YOU -- TICKET MASTER, GIG
SEEKER, AND STUB HUB.
WHICH DO YOU WANT TO USE?
>> TICKET MASTER, PLEASE.
>> OKAY.
OPENING TICKET MASTER.
I FOUND "CIRQUE DREAMS HOLIDAYS"
IN DECEMBER ON THE 22nd.
TICKETS ARE $40 TO $80.
DO YOU WANT TO PICK YOUR SEATS
OR BUY THE BEST SEATS AVAILABLE?
>> BEST SEAT AVAILABLE, PLEASE.
>> OKAY.
HOW MANY SEATS DO YOU NEED?
>> FOUR, PLEASE.
>> OKAY.
I FOUND FOUR SEATS ROW D, SEATS
SIX TO NINE.
SOUND GOOD?
>> YES.
>> OKAY.
I HAVE FOUR DREAMS FOR "CIRQUE
DREAMS HOLLANDAISE" AT THE
PARAMOUNT THEATER IN SEATTLE ON
FRIDAY, DECEMBER 22nd, AT 7:30
P.M.
THE TOTAL COMES OUT TO $394.
SAY "CONFIRM" TO PURCHASE.
>> CONFIRM.
>> OKAY.
YOU'RE ALL SET S
YOU'RE ALL SET .
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO ADD THIS TO
YOUR CALENDAR?
>> YES.
PLEASE ALSO INVITE ADAM.
>> OKAY.
I'VE SENT THIS EVENT TO ADAM
KIRK AND ADDED IT TO YOUR
CALENDAR.
>> THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME GET
THAT TAKEN CARE OF.
NOW LET ME WALK YOU THROUGH THE
COOL THINGS THAT JUST HAPPENED
HERE.
INSTEAD OF ME NEEDING WHICH
SPECIFIC SKILL TO ASK FOR,
CORTANA USED SKILL SUGGESTION TO
CONNECT ME TO BEST PLACE TO BUY
TICKETS.
AND THEN CONNECTED ME TO THAT
THIRD-PARTY SKILL.
AND BECAUSE OF MY -- I HAVE
CREDIT CARD WITH TICKET MASTER,
MY PURCHASE PROCESS WAS A
BREEZE.
CORTANA USED SKILL TRAINING
WHICH UNDERSTANDS MY -- SKILL
CHAINING WHICH UNDERSTANDS MY
OVERALL CONTENT TO USE THE NEXT
MOST-RELEVANT SKILL.
IN THIS CASE, IT WAS ADDING AN
EVENT TO MY CALENDAR.
HOW GREAT WAS THAT?
USING MY VOICE, CORTANA WAS ABLE
TO HELP ME BE SUPER PRODUCTIVE
IN WORK AND AT HOME, ALL OF THIS
DONE HANDS FREE.
THIS CALENDAR FEATURE IS
AVAILABLE NOW.
THE NEXT GENERATION OF OUR
CORTANA SKILLS KIT IS ALSO
AVAILABLE TODAY.
AND THEN E-MAIL FEATURES THE
DEMO TODAY WILL BE AVAILABLE
NEXT MONTH.
OF COURSE, CORTANA CAN HELP YOU
IN MORE PLACES THAN JUST THIS
GREAT SPEAKER.
HERE'S A QUICK LOOK IN ALL --
SOME OF THE PLACES THAT CORTANA
CAN HELP YOU BE MORE PRODUCTIVE
AND GET THINGS DONE ACROSS
WINDOWS, EDGE, SKYPE, AND THE
NEW MOBILE LAUNCHERS.
>> HEY, CORTANA, PLAY MY DANCE
MIX.
♪
>> I BOOKED YOUR WORKOUT FOR
6:00 P.M. TONIGHT.
CAN I GET YOU A RIDE?
HEY, CORTANA, WHAT'S NEXT?
>> IT'S REALLY AMAZING TO SEE
HOW CORTANA HAS EVOLVED INTO
REALLY POWERFUL IN THE DIGITAL
ASSISTANT.
I'VE BEEN THINKING A LOT WITH
MICROSOFT HOW TO DESIGN A
CONVERSATIONAL A.I. SYSTEM.
CORTANA IS JUST ONE OF THEM.
ANOTHER ONE I WANT TO BRING YOUR
ATTENTION TO IS CHAT BOTS.
WE ACTUALLY SHIPPED THE FIRST TO
CHINA 3.5 YEARS AGO.
NOW SHE HAS ABOUT 100 MILLION
USERS IN CHINA AND TALKING TO
HER AVERAGE LIKE 23 TURNS.
AND SHE'S ACTUALLY VERY, VERY
TALENTED.
YOU KNOW, IN CHINA, SHE'S EVEN
HOSTING A MORNING NEWS PROGRAM
IN SHANGHAI WITH OVER 800
MILLION VIEWERSHIP.
SHE RECENTLY ACTUALLY
DEMONSTRATED HER ABILITY TO
WRITE POEMS.
SHE PUBLISHED A POETRY BOOK.
HELPED THE CHINESE USERS TO
WRITE OVER TWO MILLION POEMS
JUST SO THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THE
SCALE, THE POEMS.
THAT'S MORE THAN ALL THE POEMS
EVER PUBLISHED IN THE HISTORY OF
CHINA.
THAT'S ONLY IN CHINA.
IN JAPAN, A YEAR LATER WE
LAUNCHED THE CHAT BOT ARENA.
AND IT'S MORE POPULAR IN JAPAN.
25% OF JAPANESE POPULATION HAVE
ALREADY IT IN JAPAN, AND SHE'S
POWERING A CHAT BOT FOR
NINTENDO'S POKEMON.
SO -- AND OF COURSE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES AS SOME OF YOU
MIGHT REMEMBER, EXACTLY A YEAR
AGO, WE CELEBRATED THE ARRIVAL
OF ZOE, OUR OWN CHAT BOT HERE IN
THE U.S.
IN JUST A YEAR, I'M HAPPY TO
TELL YOU THAT NOW SHE HAS OVER A
MILLION USERS.
JUST LIKE THE ARENA, ZOE HAS
DEVELOPED SEVERAL A.I.-DRIVEN
SENSORS LIKE VOICE RECOGNITION,
IMAGE RECOGNITION, AND THE
SOCIAL COMMENTING, AND THE
NATURAL LANGUAGE UNDERSTANDING.
PEOPLE CAN NOW RHYME WITH ZOE,
RAP AT HER, AND IT'S AMAZING.
OR CHALLENGE HER FOR A GAME OF
EXPLODING HEATHENS OR EVEN
INTERACT WITH HER NEWEST FRIEND,
A POPULAR YOUTUBER.
AMAZING THINGS YOU CAN DO WITH
CHAT BOTS.
YOU MIGHT WONDER WHY PAY SO MUCH
ATTENTION TO CHAT BOTS.
LET ME SAY THAT CHIT CHAT IS
CHARACTERISTIC OF HUMAN BEINGS.
GO HOME AND THINK ABOUT THIS.
MOST BOTS ARE INTELLIGENT AGENTS
TODAY LIKE SERIAL CORTANA, FOCUS
ON TACIT COMPLETING OR I.Q., GET
THINGS DONE WITHIN THE SKILL
TRAINING LIKE WHAT WE SAW FROM
CHRISTINA'S DEMO.
FABULOUS.
IT'S HELPING GET THINGS DONE.
BUT IT IS THE EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE OR THE E.Q. THAT
ENABLES SUSTAINED CONVERSATIONS
OR DIALOGUES WHICH WILL BE
CRITICAL TO TRULY UNDERSTAND THE
HUMANE USERS.
SO BY ENGAGING WITH THE PEOPLE
AND ON A MUCH MORE SOCIAL AND
PERSONAL LEVEL IN OUR CHAT BOTS,
DEVELOPING THE E.Q.s.
SO LEARNING HOW TO REACT,
RESPOND, AND BASED ON THE DATA
THAT FROM THOSE INTERACTIONS.
WE CAN TAKE THOSE LEARNINGS AND
APPLY THEM TO MANY OTHER
PRODUCTS.
OF COURSE IN MICROSOFT, NOT ONLY
WE DO THOSE CONVERSATIONAL A.I.
PRODUCTS, YOU KNOW, WE ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR A.I. INVESTMENT
WILL BE INFUSED INTO ALL
MICROSOFT PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
THAT DRIVE DEEPER IN THE MORE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES.
THE FIRST PLACE WE START IS
WINDOWS.
WINDOWS IS ALREADY USING MACHINE
LEARNING AND COMPUTER VISION,
FOR EXAMPLE, TO HELP PERSONALIZE
YOUR PHOTOS AND VIDEOS.
IT'S REALLY AMAZING IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT -- THE EXPLOSION OF
DIGITAL PHOTOS.
ON AVERAGE FOR WINDOWS USER,
EVERY YEAR THE USER WILL TAKE
52,000 PHOTOS.
THERE'S FLOW WAY YOU CAN KEEP --
THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN KEEP
TRACK OF SO MANY PHOTOS AND DO
SOMETHING WITH THE PHOTOS UNTIL
NOW WITH THE HELP OF A.I.
LET'S ROLL THE VIDEO AND SHOW
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING WITH
WINDOWS PHOTO AND VIDEO.
♪
>> TODAY WE CAPTURE MORE PHOTOS
AND VIDEOS THAN EVER BEFORE IN
HISTORY.
AND WE ARE BUILDING A SUITE OF
A.I.-DRIVEN TOOLS WITHIN
MICROSOFT PHOTOS TO TRANSFORM
THE WAY THE NEXT GENERATION OF
WINDOWS USERS DREAMS, CAPTURES,
AND EXPRESSES THEMSELVES.
THIS MONTH WE SHIPPED A NEW
SEARCH SYSTEM THAT USES MACHINE
LEARNING TO LET YOU FIND PEOPLE,
PLACES, AND THINGS IN YOUR
PHOTOS.
TO TO GIVE YOU A STARTING POINT
FOR CREATING VIDEOS, WE'VE
CREATED SYSTEMS THAT
AUTOMATICALLY GENERATE MOVIES
FROM YOUR MEDIA.
SPECIAL EFFECTS ARE SOME OF THE
MOST COVETED FEATURES BY THE
GEN-Z AUDIENCE.
WE ARE USING COMPUTER VISION AND
A.I. TO TRACK OBJECTS IN YOUR
VIDEOS.
JUST INK A DOODLE, ANKLE IT, AND
WATCH IT FOLLOW SOMETHING --
ANCHOR IT, AND WATCH IT FOLLOW
SOMETHING IN PHOTO.
WE'RE EXCITED TO BRING YOU
DIGITAL EXPERIENCES WITH A.I.
COMING TO OVER 250 MILLION
DEVICES EVERY MONTH.
>> EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BECOME
MOTHER NATURE INTELLIGEN
MOTHER NATUR
MORE INTELLIGENT.
AS YOU THINK ABOUT MANAGING
FILES, CREATING, ALL THOSE
THINGS.
BUT REALLY THE BIGGEST A.I.
DELIVERY VEHICLE IN MICROSOFT IS
OFFICE 365.
WITH I A -- WITH A TOTAL OF 150
MILLION USERS, A.I. IS WORKING.
I'M GOING TO INVITE ROB UP TO
SHOW COOL FEATURES, WHAT WE DO
WITH A.I. AND OFFICE.
ROB?
>> THANK YOU, HARRY.
HI, EVERYBODY.
I'M ROB HOWARD.
I WORK IN THE OFFICE PRODUCT
MARKETING TEAM.
I'M EXCITED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
A.I.-POWERED TOOLS WE'RE ADDING
TO OFFICE TO HELP PEOPLE DO
THEIR BEST WORK.
THE TRUTH IS WE'VE USED A.I. IN
OFFICE FOR MANY YEARS.
YOU CAN THINK OF FEATURES LIKE
SPELLCHECK AND FLASH FILL AND
RECOMMENDED CHARTS THAT ARE A
STANDARD PART OF THE OFFICE YOU
KNOW AND LOVE.
WITH THE ADVENT OF OFFICE 365,
WHEN WE TOOK THE CLOUD AND
DEEPLY INTEGRATED IT WITH ALL
THE APPS ACROSS OFFICE, IT
REALLY ACCELERATED OUR PROGRESS
IN A.I.
AS OFFICE 365 HAS GROWN, IT'S
BECOME ONE OF THE BIGGEST
VEHICLES FOR DELIVERING A.I.
TECHNOLOGY TO REAL PEOPLE AND
HELPING THEM GET REAL VALUE OUT
OF IT.
YOU'LL SEE HOW WE'RE USING WORLD
DATA, USER DATA, AND ESPECIALLY
WORK DATA TO HELP SAVE PEOPLE
TIME, TO HELP THEM FOCUS ON
THINGS THAT MATTER MOST TO THEM
AND HELP THEM BE BETTER WRITERS
AND UNLOCK HIDDEN JITS SIGHT I
AND UNLOCK HIDDEN JITS SIGIN--
HIDDEN INSIGHTS IN DATA.
I'LL START BY SHOWING SOME OF MY
FAVORITE FEATURES, FEATURES THAT
I USE EVERY DAY.
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN SOME, BUT LIKE
ANY GOOD A.I. THEY'VE GOTTEN
BETTER AS MORE PEOPLE HAVE USED
THEM.
I WANT TO SHARE THE LATEST.
THEN I'M GOING TO SHOW YOUR NO
THEN I'M GOING TO SHOW YOUR NEW
WAYS WE'RE BRINGING A.I. TO
OFFICES IN THE NEXT MONTHS.
THIS IS PART OF MY OFFICE 365
SUBSCRIPTION.
I'M WORKING ON A PRESENTATION
FOR THE CONTOSO QUAD 8 COPTER
PORTFOLIO.
I SPENT MOST OF MY CAREER AS AN
ENGINEER.
ACTUALLY BUILDING IMPACTFUL
PRESENTATIONS TAKES MORE TIME
AND EFFORT THAN I'D LIKE.
AND JUST A SECOND, COME BACK UP,
BUILDING IMPACTFUL PRESENTATIONS
TAKES TIME, EFFORT, AND FRANKLY,
DESIGN SKILLS THAT I JUST DON'T
HAVE.
LUCKILY THAT'S WHERE DESIGNER
COMES IN.
DESIGNER LETS ME FOCUS ON THE
CONTENT OF THE PRESENTATION, AND
IT TAKES CARE OF CREATING A
BEAUTIFUL REPRESENTATION OF MY
IDEAS SO THAT'S AS IMPACTFUL ON
MY AUDIENCE AS POSSIBLE.
I'M GOING TO START ON THE TITLE
SIDE.
YOU SEE IT'S BORING, BUT I HAVE
A FEW IMAGES THAT CAN SPRUCE IT
UP.
I'M GOING TO DROP THEM INTO THE
SLIDE.
NORMALLY I'D START REARRANGING
THEM, CROPPING THEM, RESIZING
THEM TO CREATE A LAYOUT THAT I
WAS HAPPY WITH.
DESIGNER IS ALWAYS WORKING FOR
ME IN THE BACKGROUND.
WHEN I ADD THAT CONTENT TO THE
SLIDE, IT AUTOMATICALLY POPS UP
FOR ME WITH ADVICE ON HOW TO LAY
THEM OUT.
AND AS I CLICK THROUGH THEM,
YOU'LL SEE IT'S CREATING THESE
BEAUTIFUL DESIGNS THAT ARE
FEATURING THE CONTENT I'VE ADDED
TO THE SLIDE.
IT SEEMS SIMPLE BECAUSE CORTANA
MADE IT THAT WAY.
THINGS GOING ON LIKE SALIENT
RECOGNITION AND COLOR ANALYSIS.
YOU'LL SEE THAT EVEN AS IT'S
CROPPING AND RE-SIZING IMAGES TO
BUILD A BEAUTIFUL LAYOUT, IT
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE HAND AND
QUAD COCKPITO
QUAD COCKPIT O
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE HAND AND
QUAD COCKPIT COP -- QUAD COPTO
QUAD COCKPIT COP -- QUAD COPTPER
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE HAND AND
QUAD COCKPIT COP -- QUAD COPTPE
ARE THE CENTER OF THE CENTER OF
THE IMAGE.
IT FOUND THE BLUES IN THE SKY
AND WATER, IT'S ABLE TO ECHO
THOSE IN THE SLIDE THROUGH COLOR
ANALYSIS.
IF I GO TO THE NEXT SLIDES,
YOU'LL SEE I HAVE A PRETTY LONG
IMAGE HERE WITH A LOT GOING ON.
DIFFERENT FACES, A JACKET.
IT WOULD BE EASY TO TAKE JUST
THE CENTER OR LEFT SIDE.
IT'S ACTUALLY ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THE ONE IN-FOCUS FACE IN THE
IMAGE -- AND AS I PAGE THROUGH,
YOU SEE IT'S MAKING THE FACE THE
HERO OF THAT IMAGE.
I TOLD YOU THESE WERE GETTING
SMARTER.
ONE OF THE TWLAS DESIGNER IS
GETTING -- WAYS THAT DESIGNER IS
GETTING SMARTER, IT CAN DEAL
WITH MORE CONTENT.
NOT JUST IMAGES BUT TEXT.
YOU'LL SEE A SET OF DEVELOPMENT
MILESTONES.
THE DESIGNERS IS USING NATURAL
LANGUAGE PROCESSING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY
A TIMELINE, A SERIES OF MONTHS.
IT'S ABLE TO CREATE A BEAUTIFUL
REPRESENTATION OF THAT TIMELINE
THAT MAKES THE MILESTONES POP
FOR MY AUDIENCE.
OR I CAN GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE
WITH A SEQUENCE OF STEPS.
DESIGNER RECOGNIZE THAT'S AND
LETS ME CREATE A DIAGRAM THAT
CLEARLY OUTLINES THE FLOW.
IT'S EVEN ABLE TO DO THINGS LIKE
PULL OUT THE VERBS FROM THESE
STEPS AND USE THEM A A QUICK
HEADER.
-- USE THEM AS A QUICK HEADER.
IN SECONDS, I'VE USED A.I. TO
CREATE A MORE IMPACTFUL
PRESENTATION IN POWERPOINT.
NOW WE'LL SWITCH TO WORD AND SEE
THREE MORE OF MY FAVORITE POWER
FEATURES ALREADY IN OFFICE.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
ANOTHER A.I.-POWERED ASSISTANT
EDITOR.
NOW EDITOR GOES WAY BEYOND THE
SPELLING AND GRAMMAR CHECKING
THAT YOU'RE USED TO.
IT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT MACHINE
LEARNING, NATURAL LANGUAGE
PROCESSING, AND EXTENSIVE AND
ONGOING INPUT FROM HUMAN
LINGUISTS TO MAKE ME A BETTER
WRITER.
IF I SCROLL DOWN, YOU'LL SEE A
BUNCH OF EXAMPLES OF GOLD DOTTED
UNDERLINES.
AND IF I DRILL INTO THEM, YOU'LL
SEE THAT EDITOR CAN CATCH
EVERYTHING FROM OVERUSED CLICHES
LIKE "THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX" TO
JARGON LIKE "HEAD HUNTING."
AND EVEN POTENTIAL BIAS LIKE
"YOUNG BLOOD."
AND FOR EACH OF THESE, IT NOT
ONLY DETECTS THE PROBLEM, BUT IT
SUGGESTS A SOLUTION LIKE MAYBE
USING NEW PEOPLE INSTEAD OF
YOUNG BLOOD.
IF I'M INTERESTED IN LEARNING
MORE ABOUT THAT RECOMMENDATION,
I CAN DRILL IN TO SEE MORE AND
GET DETAIL ABOUT ITS
RECOMMENDATION AS WELL AS OTHER
EXAMPLES.
I CAN CUSTOMIZE THE WAY EDITOR
WORKS.
IF I FEEL LIKE I WANT TO HOLD ON
TO MY VAGUE ADJECTIVES AND MY
OXFORD COMAS, I CAN DO THAT IN
ORDER TO PRESERVE MY PERSONAL
STYLE.
WE'VE SEEN A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES
OF HOW A.I. IS HELPING ME CREATE
BETTER WORK, BUT A.I. CAN ALSO
HELP ME WORK MORE NATURALLY
ALONG THE WAY.
ONE THING WE'VE SEEN PEOPLE DO A
LOT OF IS PRINT OFF DOCUMENTS
LIKE THESE AND TAKE A PEN AND
WRITE COMMENTS IN THE MARGIN OR
MARK THEM UP WITH EDITS.
AND THIS SOUNDS SILLY, BUT IT
SORT OF MAKES SENSE.
IT FEELS MINORITY LEADER US
IT FEELS MINORITY LEADER U-- IT
FEELS NATURAL TO USE A PEN.
USING A PEN ACTIVATES YOUR BRAIN
MORE DEEPLY THAN USING A
KEYBOARD OR MOUSE.
WITH A.I. AND INK EDITOR IN
WORD, WE CAN MAKE USING A
DIGITAL PEN AND INK FEEL AS
NATURAL AS PAPER, JUST WITHOUT
ALL THE PRINTING AND SCANNING.
SO I CAN DO THINGS LIKE CHOOSE A
RED PEN.
OF COURSE, I CAN WRITE IN THE
MARGIN.
BUT IN IS BETTER BECAUSE I CAN
MAKE EDITS LIKE STRIKING THROUGH
A SENTENCE, AND THEY'RE
EFFECTIVE IN THE DOCUMENT.
I CAN CHANGE TO A HIGHLIGHT HER,
AND INK EDITOR UNDERSTANDS I NO
LONGER WANT TO STRIKE SOMETHING
OUT BUT ADD EMPHASIS TO IT.
AND I CAN USE GESTURES LIKE A
CIRCLE OR A SCRIBBLE, AND INK
EDIT UNDERSTANDS WHAT I
INTENDED.
I WANT TO ADD CONTENT TO THE
DOCUMENT.
YOU'LL SEE I NEED TO GET A
PROJECT MILESTONE TABLE AND A
FORECAST CHART.
I KNOW THAT THESE ARE THINGS MY
COLLEAGUES WERE WORKING ON IN
OTHER DOCUMENTS.
NORMALLY WHAT I DO HERE IS I
LEAVE WORD, GO INTO A TOOL LIKE
OUTLOOK OR ONEDRIVE OR
SHAREPOINT TO SEARCH FOR
INFORMATION, ONCE I FINALLY
FOUND THE DOCUMENT, I WOULD GO
DRILL THROUGH IT AND FIND THE
TABLE THAT I NEEDED OR CHART I
WAS LOOKING FOR.
I'D COPY THAT OUT, COME BACK TO
WORD, AND I'D INSERT IT.
THAT WOULD BREAK UP THE FLOW OF
MY WORK.
WITH A NEW A.I.-POWERED FEATURE
IN WORD CALLED TAP, I CAN
DIRECTLY WITHIN THE FLOW OF MY
WORK AND TOOL I'M USING TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ALL OF MY
ORGANIZATION'S KNOWLEDGE IN
ORDER TO FIND THE RIGHT CONTENT.
YOU'LL SEE THAT IT CAN DO THINGS
NOW LIKE FILTER DOWN TO SPECIFIC
CONTENT TYPE.
I'M LOOKING FOR A MILESTONE
TABLE.
I CAN CHOOSE TABLES.
THE FIRST THING -- FIRST LIST TO
COME UP IS THE FABRIC CAM CASE
STUDY WHERE I KNOW THE PROJECT
MILESTONES ARE.
WHEN I DRILL IN, YOU CAN SEE
IT'S NOT THE ENTIRE DOCUMENT.
IT'S BREAKING DOWN THE SPECIFIC
ELEMENTS THAT I MIGHT WANT TO
REUSE.
AND HERE I SEE THE PROJECT
MILESTONE TABLE THAT I CAN ADD
WITH A SINGLE TAP.
AND BECAUSE IT'S STILL A
FULL-FEATURED TABLE, I CAN STYLE
IT TO LOOK GOOD IN THIS
DOCUMENT.
NOW THIS CASH FLOW FORECAST
CHART DIDN'T SHOW UP AS ONE OF
THE TOP ITEMS.
THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE TAP IS
ACTUALLY TIED INTO PERSONALIZED
SEARCH POWERED BY ONEDRIVE AND
SHAREPOINT SO THAT WHEN I TYPE
IN FORECAST, I'M GOING TO GET
RESULTS THAT I HAVE ACCESS TO
AND ONES THAT ARE MOST
MEANINGFUL AND RELEVANT TO ME.
YOU'LL SEE THAT THE CASH FLOW
FORECAST IS THE TOP ITEM HERE.
I CAN DRILL IN AND FIND THE
CHART, ADD TO MY DOCUMENT.
AND BECAUSE IT'S A FULL FEATURED
CHART INSIDE A WORD, I CAN DO
THINGS LIKE ADD A TREND LINE,
AGAIN WITHOUT HAVING TO LEAVE
THE FLOW OF MY WORK.
I'M SHOWING YOU MY FOUR FAVORITE
A.I. POWER FEATURES ALREADY IN
OFFICE.
I'M GOING TO SWITCH TO WHAT'S
COMING NEXT.
WE'RE GOING TO START INSIDE OF
EXCEL.
IF THERE'S ONE THING WE'VE
LEARNED FROM WORK IN A.I., IT'S
THAT DATA'S AN INCREDIBLY
VALUABLE RESOURCE.
WITH HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE USING
EXCEL, THERE'S A LOT OF DATA IN
EXCEL SPREADSHEETS.
A LOT OF THE DATA LOOKS LIKE
THIS -- A SIMPLE TABLE, BUT
THERE'S COLUMNS, TEAMS, CATEGORY
LINE ITEMS.
AND I DON'T LOOKING AT IT GET A
SENSE OF HOW THIS WORKS, WHAT
ARE THE TRENDS, WHAT ARE THE
WAYS THAT THESE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES AND COLUMNS AFFECT
THE VALUES?
AND I COULD, OF COURSE, USE ALL
THE TOOLS IN EXCEL TO CREATE
CHARTS AND PIVOT TABLES TO
ANALYZE IT IN A LOT OF WAYS,
THAT WOULD TAKE ME A LOT OF TIME
EVEN AS AN EXCEL EXPERT.
BUT WITHIN SIGHTS WHICH IS
COMING TO OFFICE INSIDERS THIS
MONTH, I HAVE AN A.I.-POWERED
ASSISTANTS THAT WILL DO ALL THE
LEGWORK FOR ME.
I CAN RUN INSIGHTS ON THIS
PARTICULAR DATA SET AND REALLY
QUICKLY GET A SENSE OF HOW IT
WORKS.
I CAN SEE THINGS LIKE SPEND
INCREASE OVER TIME.
I CAN SEE THAT IF I BREAK DOWN
THIS DATA BY TYPE, PAYROLL HAS A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER SPEND THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
IF I DRILL INTO MORE INSIGHTS, I
CAN SEE DEEPER THINGS LIKE IF I
ISOLATE JUST STOCK COMPENSATION,
I CAN SEE A SIGNIFICANT OUTLIER.
I MIGHT WANT TO DRILL INTO THAT
FURTHER.
I'M GOING TO HIT INSERT CHART.
AND IT WILL CREATE A PIVOT TABLE
IN EXCEL TIED TO THE DATA
SHOWING THIS EXACT INSIGHT.
I CAN MOUSE OVER HERE AND SEE
THE OUTLIER OCCURRED ON
SEPTEMBER, 2013.
BUT I WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
SOURCE, SO I CAN USE EXCEL'S
FUNCTIONALITY IN PIVOT TABLES TO
BREAK IT DOWN BY TEAM.
MMD I CAN FIND THAT THE
ENGINEERING TEAM IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR OUTLIER AND GO AND
INVESTIGATE FURTHER.
IN JUST A FEW SECONDS, I WAS
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THE DATA SET
AND FIND KEY INSIGHTS THAT I MAY
WANT TO INVESTIGATE FURTHER.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO SWITCH GEARS
TO THINGS THAT ARE BLEEDING
EDGE.
IN FACT, SO BLEEDING EDGE THAT
I'M GOING TO CONNECT TO A
MACHINE IN DUBLIN TO SHOW IT TO
YOU.
EARLIER WE SAW HOW IN TAP I CAN
USE ORGANIZATIONAL KNOWLEDGE IN
ORDER TO MORE QUICKLY ACCESS
WHAT I NEED AND INCORPORATE IT
INTO MY OWN WORK.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO SEE HOW WORD
ON LINE CAN CONNECT TO THAT IN
ORDER TO HELP YOU UNDERSTAND
YOUR COMPANY BETTER.
THAT ORGANIZATIONAL KNOWLEDGE
CAN BE A BARRIER IN ADDITION TO
A HELP.
I KNOW AT COMPANIES LIKE
MICROSOFT, LIKE PROBABLY EVERY
LARGE COMPANI, IT CAN SOMETIMES
FEEL LIKE WE HAVE OUR OWN
LANGUAGE ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO ACRONYMS.
WHEN YOU MOVE TEAMS OR WORK WITH
DIFFERENT GROUPS, IT CAN A
BARRIER TO UNDERSTANDING.
WE'RE CONNECTING WORD ON LINE
DEEPLY TO THE MICROSOFT GRAPH
AND WORK KNOWLEDGE THAT I HAVE.
WHEN I OPEN A DOCUMENT, WORD
ONLINE CAN USE THAT KNOWLEDGE
PULLING FROM EMAILS I HAVE
ACCESS TO AND DOCUMENTS I HAVE
ACCESS TO TO AUTOMATICALLY
IDENTIFY ACRONYMS IN THE
DOCUMENT.
AND THEN WITHIN THE TOOL I'M
USING, IDENTIFY THEM FOR ME SO I
CAN SEE AI&R IS ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND RESEARCH, OR
SEE THAT NPS MEANS NET PROMOTER
SCORE.
IT FOUND IT FROM FILES I HAVE
ACCESS TO IN MY ORGANIZATION.
IF I HAVE ONE THAT I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND, I SEE BPO MEANS
BUSINESS PLANNING OPERATIONS,
BUT WHAT EXACTLY IS THAT?
I CAN SEE THE SOURCE OF THE
INFORMATION AND GET AN EXCERPT
TO UNDERSTAND THAT BUSINESS
PLANNING AND OPERATIONS IS A
TEAM AT MICROSOFT.
NOW I'M GOING TO SHOW MY LAST
TWO DEMOS, AND THEY'RE BOTH IN
OUTLOOK.
OUTLOOK AND RECENT FEATURES LIKE
FOCUS INBOX HAS DONE A LOT OF
WORK TO HELP ME SPEND LESS TIME
MANAGING MY INBOX AND MORE TIME
FOCUSING ON WHAT MATTERS TO ME.
AND SOON, OUTLOOK'S GOING TO
HELP ME DO THAT WITHIN AN
E-MAIL.
IF I OPEN UP THIS E-MAIL HERE,
YOU'LL SEE IT'S GOT A LOT OF
TEXT, BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING
TO USE NATURAL LANGUAGE
PROCESSING TO IDENTIFY THE
ACTION ITEMS IN THIS TEXT
AUTOMATICALLY.
OPEN UP THE E-MAIL.
I'VE GOT A QUICK VIDEO I CAN
SHOW.
LIKE I TOLD YOU, THIS IS
BLEEDING EDGE STUFF THAT'S
COMING SOON.
THERE WE GO.
IT POPPED IN.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
YOU SEE THAT AS I'M LOOKING
THROUGH THE E-MAIL, WE'RE USING
NATURAL LANGUAGE PROCESSING ON
THE E-MAIL TO IDENTIFY THE
ACTION ITEMS IN IT
AUTOMATICALLY.
YOU SEE THE UNDERLINES UNDER
"DID YOU SEE THE MESSAGE THE
PARTNER SENT OUT."
IT'S PROVIDING SUGGESTED
RESPONSES.
THESE AREN'T CANNED, NOT JUST
YES, NO, MAYBE.
IT SAID, DID YOU SEE THE UPDATE
THE PARTNER SENT US, AND
RESPONSES ARE THINGS LIKE, YEAH,
I SAW IT, OR NO, WHAT WAS IT.
IT'S TAILORED TO THE SPECIFIC
ACTION ITEM.
WHEN I SAY, NO, WHAT WAS IT,
OUTLOOK AUTOMATICALLY CREATES A
REPLY, IT QUOTES THAT ACTION
ITEM, AND INSERTS MY REPLY
DIRECTLY IN LINE.
AND I CAN DO THAT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE E-MAIL RESPONDING TO EACH
OF THESE ACTION ITEMS SO I CAN
REALLY QUICKLY MAKE SURE I'M
COVERING THE ACTION ITEMS AND
RESPOND TO THEM EVEN ON THE GO.
THE LAST FEATURE I WANT TO SHOW
IS IN OUTLOOK MOBILE.
AND I HAVE A FEELING THAT THIS
FEATURE WAS BUILT EXACTLY FOR
ME.
ANYBODY WHO WORKS WITH YOU WILL
TELL ME THAT I AM A PERT PET --
PERPETUALLY LATE PERSON.
I HAVE A TENDENCY TO SCHEDULE
MEETINGS BACK TO BACK.
I DON'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT HOW
MUCH TIME IT WILL TAKE TO TRAVEL
BETWEEN THEM.
IT OFTEN HAPPENS THAT BY THE
TIME THE OUTLOOK REMINDER SHOWS
UP TO TELL ME I NEED TO BE THERE
IN 15 MINUTES, IT IS GOING TO
TAKE ME WAY TOO LONG TO GET
ACROSS TOWN.
LUCKILY, OUTLOOK AND CORTANA
WILL SOON SOLVE THAT PROBLEM FOR
ME.
YOU SEE THAT CORTANA IS GIVING
ME A NOTIFICATION THAT I NEED TO
LEAVE BY 5:05 TO ARRIVE ON TIME
FOR DINNER WITH FRIENDS.
IT'S TELLING ME IT'S GOING TO
TAKE 24 MINUTES TO GET TO THE
LAKE HOUSE BASED ON MY CURRENT
LOCATION AND CURRENT TRAFFIC
CONDITIONS.
SO I KNOW I'M NOT LATE.
I CAN EVEN FORCE TOUCH INTO THE
NOTIFICATION SO I CAN SEE A
ROUTE TO THE DESTINATION THAT
WE'RE GOING TO AND DEEP LINK
INTO MY FAVORITE MAPPING
APPLICATIONS TO GET DIRECTIONS.
SEE THAT WAS A QUICK LAP AROUND
ALL OF THE A.I.-INFUSED FEATURES
IN OFFICE, BUT REALLY THAT'S
JUST A DROP IN THE BUCKET.
WE'VE BEEN HARD AT WORK ADDING
A.I. TO OFFICE FOR YEARS, AND
THERE ARE LITERALLY DOZENS OF
FEATURES THAT ARE A.I. POWERED.
YOU'LL SEE THINGS LIKE QUICK
STARTER AND RESEARCHER.
YOU'LL SEE THINGS LIKE MY
ANALYTICS, INK TO MATH, INK TO
SHAPE.
ONE OF MOO
ONE OF MOY FAVORITE, MATH
ASSISTANTS.
AT THE BOOTH WE'LL TELL YOU ALL
ABOUT THE FULL STORY OF OFFICE
AND A.I.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ROB.
JUST A LOT OF VERY EXCITING, YOU
KNOW, A.I. FEATURES THAT WE, YOU
KNOW, ALREADY INFUSED INTO MY
MICROSOFT PRODUCTS LIKE OFFICE
365.
AT MICROSOFT WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN OFFER THIS
KIND OF INCREDIBLE A.I.
EXPERIENCES TO DEVELOPERS AND
PARTNERS.
HOW CAN WE HELP THEM TO VIEW THE
JUST AS EXCITING A.I.
APPLICATIONS?
I TALKED EARLY ABOUT A.I.
PLATFORMS AND OTHER THINGS H. I
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT IN A
KEY TO MAKING GREATER A.I. APPS
IS THE DATA.
THAT'S WHERE MICROSOFT IS IN A
UNIQUE POSITION TO OFFER OUR
PART INCREASE AND DEVELOPERS --
PARTNERS AND DEVELOP FORCE HELP
DEBUT A.I. APPLICATIONS BY
PROVIDING THEM MICROSOFT GRAPHS.
IT INCLUDES A GRAPH LIKE WHAT
YOU CAN GET FROM BING AND
LINKEDIN, AND ALSO WORK
KNOWLEDGE GRAPH FROM OFFICE 365
DYNAMICS.
IMAGINE ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS AND
PARTNERS, THEY CAN COMBINE
MICROSOFT GRAPHS WITH THEIR OWN
BUSINESS DATA AND KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THEIR OWN USERS.
TO BUILD APPLICATIONS FOR
CUSTOMERS, EMPLOYEES, AND THEIR
BUSINESS.
WE ARE VERY, VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE OPPORTUNITIES THERE THAT WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER.
AT MICROSOFT WE HAVE WORKED LONG
AND HARD TO BRING MANY GRAPHS
TOGETHER, CONTAINED WITHIN A
COMPLIANCE BOUNDARY.
THAT ACTUALLY CONFORMS TO OUR
PRIVACY COMPLIANCE AND ALSO DATA
POLICIES.
THAT'S VERY, VERY IMPORTANT TO
ENTERPRISES.
THOSE INVESTMENTS REALLY
UNDERSCORE WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING IN THE MICROSOFT A.I.
AND RESEARCH, FIVE THINGS
ACTUALLY I TALKED TO YOU.
I JUST WANT TO FINISH MY
PRESENTATION BY MENTIONING SOME
ALSO IMPORTANT AND EXCITING
TOPICS NOWADAYS AS PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT A.I. DEVELOPMENT IN
PARTNERSHIP, IN SOCIETY, AND
ALSO IN ETHICS.
AS WE EMBRACE THIS A.I. FUND
HERE, WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT, YOU KNOW, CONCERNS ABOUT
A.I. DO EXIST.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE SOME UNIVERSAL DESIGN
PRINCIPLES AND VALUES THAT HELP
GUIDE OUR THINKING, OUR DESIGN
AND DEVELOPMENT.
WE TAKE IN THE ETHICAL APPROACH
TO A.I. DESIGN SERIOUSLY.
OUR PRINCIPLED APPROACH IS
CRITICAL CONDITION, AND WE DO
THIS THOUGHTFULLY AND IN A
TRUSTWORTHY WAY, BOTH INSIDE
MICROSOFT AND ALSO OUTSIDE.
INTERNALLY WE HAVE ORGANIZED AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT HELPS
ENSURE THE ADHERENCE THE
PRINCIPLES IN OUR OWN A.I.
DEVELOPMENT.
AND EXTERNALLY, WE RECOGNIZE
THAT WE CANNOT DO THAT ALONE.
WE CO-FOUNDED THE PARTNERSHIP ON
A.I. JUST OVER A YEAR AGO.
THIS SAY NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WHERE YOU SEE MANY LEADING TECH
COMPANIES AND ACADEMIA, CIVIL
SOCIETIES, AND MANY, MANY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WHO
ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT THE FUTURE
OF A.I. DEVELOPMENTS.
THIS IS SET UP TO STUDY, FORM
LATE, AND SHARE THE BEST
PRACTICES ON A.I. ON OFFICE.
WE BELIEVE WE NEED TO GIVE BACK
AS WE DEVELOP A.I.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK A
REPRESENTATIVE THE A.I. FOR
EARTH PROGRAM.
THEY ARE HERE TODAY.
I ENCOURAGE YOU STOP BY THEIR
BOOTHS TO TALK TO THEM, WHAT
THEY DO FOR OUR SOCIETY.
FINALLY I WOULD SAY AS A FIRST
GENERATION TO LEAD WITH A.I., WE
PLAY A VERY UNIQUE ROLE IN
SHAPING THE FUTURE.
AS WE WILL DO SO, THAT IS
ACTUALLY THOUGHTFUL.
THAT IS REALLY OUR NUMBER-ONE
FOCUS IN MICROSOFT.
SO THERE'S HAY LO
SO THERE'S HAYA LOT WE DON'T KN
ABOUT A.I.'S IMPACT YET.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT A.I. HAS
A LOT OF POTENTIAL TO REALLY
IMPROVE LIVES, AND IT'S
HPPENING NOW.
LET ME SHARE A STORY ABOUT HOW
A.I. HAS GIVEN VOICES TO THOSE
WHO OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE HAD
NONE.
>> A COMMUNICATION APP FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE NONVERBAL, AND IS
SUPPORTS THEM IN EXPRESSING
THEMSELVES.
>> MY DAUGHTER HAS AUTISM.
I FIND IT DIFFICULT TO
COMMUNICATE, AND HE CAN GET
UPSET IF HE CAN'T MAKE HIMSELF
UNDERSTOOD.
I TOOK WHAT WE USED AT HOME WITH
SYMBOLS THAT MY MOM WOULD PRINT
OUT, LAMINATE, CUT OUT, AND PUT
THEM INTO FOLDERS, AND I JUST
THOUGHT I COULD MAKE THAT EASIER
IF WE DID IT ON A APP AND MORE
FUN FOR ROWAN BECAUSE HE LOVES
TECHNOLOGY.
>> THE UNDERLYING A.I.
TECHNOLOGY WHICH IS USED IS THE
SAME TECHNOLOGY WHICH POWERS THE
SWIFT AUNG SAN SUU KYIBOARD.
WE USE A.I. TECHNOLOGY TO BE
ABLE TO LEARN FROM THE USER'S
BEHAVIOR, TO SEE WHAT THEY